GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THIS EVENING'S LISTENING
SESSION OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THANK YOU CONCORD FOR HOSTING
US AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR FOR JOINING
US ALSO I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM FRAZIER I REPRESENT THE
ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THE
DELTA REGION BUT I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
WE ARE HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU
NOT ME OR MY COLLEAGUES WE'RE
HERE TO DISCUSS FAMILIES WHO
LIVE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
I DD AFFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF OUR BACKGROUND
OR WHERE WE LIVE R.
IDG POPULATION CONTINUES
TO GROW AND WE MUST PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND SUPPORT
TO OUR IDT FRIENDS NEIGHBORS
AND OUR FAMILY MEMBERS IN THE
CAPITAL WE DON'T HEAR FROM YOU
ALL AS MUCH AS WE'D LIKE TO
SO WE BROUGHT THE COMMITTEE
TO ALL OF YOU IT IS IMPORTANT
TO US THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AND THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE ON IT DE IS LISTENING
AND WILL RESPOND AND LIKE WE'RE
LISTENING TO YOU YOUR IDEAS AND
CONCERNS FOR SPANISH SPEAKING
FRIENDS LISA WAS GRACIOUS
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE HEADSETS TO
TRANSLATE THE HEARING THANK
YOU LISA IF WE WERE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE YOU ONE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO CATCH EVER AFTER THE
HEARING AND SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS
AND CONCERNS DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT SO THE YOUR COMMENTS
BE MAY BE CAPTURED ALSO VIDEO
WILL BE AVAILABLE AFTER THE
HEARING POSTED ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WITH CLOSED
CAPTIONING FEEL FREE TO USE
IT AS WELL IN FEEL FREE TO USE
IT AS A REFERENCE FOR THOSE
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO HEAR
US SO WHAT IS SELECT COMMITTEE
SO I COMMITTEES ARE DIFFERENT
FROM STANDING LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES WE DON'T HOLD
HEARINGS ON PENDING LEGISLATION
THE LEGISLATION CAN HAPPEN
WITH YOUR INPUT THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE IS HAS HAD ITS FIRST
REGIONAL HEARING IN FRESNO LAST
WEEK WHAT AN AMAZING TURNOUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF RANDALL
AND I LEARNED THAT IN FRESNO
TRANSPORTATION IS ONE OF THE
BIGGER OBSTACLES FACING THE
REGION BUT MY BIGGEST TAKEAWAY
WAS THAT WE NEEDED TO RESERVE
MORE TIME TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
YOUR CONCERNS TODAY WE REDUCE
THE PANELISTS PRESENTATION SO
THAT WE HAVE MORE TIME FOR YOU
WE WILL FIRST BEGIN WITH LISA
CLIMBED UP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER EAST
BAY WHO WILL TALK ABOUT THE
SERVICES THEY OFFER AND WHAT
OBSTACLES AND CHALLENGES SHE
SEES WITHIN HER ROLE FOLLOWING
ME SO WE WILL HEAR FROM KRISTIN
BREA ORIGINAL PROVIDER WHO JUST
WHO WILL DISCUSS THE OBSTACLES
AND SUCCESSES AS A PROVIDER
THIS WILL BE FOLLOWED BY MY
TWO FRIENDS AUDRA AND NICOLE TO
SOLVE ADVOCATES WHO LIVE IN THE
BAY AREA THEN WE WILL INVITE
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
TO BE CANDID AND HONEST ABOUT
YOUR EXPERIENCES WE WILL ALLOW
EACH INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC TWO TO THREE MINUTES
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES TO LET
THEM INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND
SHARE WITH YOU WHY THEY ARE
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
THANK YOU CHAIR FRAZIER I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM GRAYSON
AND I REPRESENT THE FOURTEENTH
DISTRICT WHICH YOU ARE IN AND
-- I'M SITTING UP AT THE DÍAS
AGAIN WHERE I SENT -- PRIOR TO
-- GOING TO THE ASSEMBLY I AM
-- NOT A STRANGER TO THE IDT
COMMUNITY AND -- NEITHER IS
THE ID THE COMMUNITY A STRANGER
TO ME I HAVE BEEN AROUND IT
SENSE MY BIRTH ACTUALLY AND
HAVE GROWN UP IN A HOME WITH
MY SISTER SHERRY WHO -- HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE GREATEST THINGS
THAT EVER HAPPENED TO ME IN MY
LIFE AND -- I WAS ABLE TO FLY
ARE OUT THIS PAST YEAR SO THAT
WE COULD PRESENT A RESOLUTION
TOGETHER ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AND TO SHOW FOLKS THAT
-- THE IDT COMMUNITY IS HERE
AND IT NEEDS TO BE RECOGNIZED
AND TO UNDERSTAND THAT WITH
THE RIGHT RESOURCES WITH --
ALL THE THINGS A LINE THE WAY
THEY SHOULD BE AND AND -- THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE RESOURCES
THOSE IN THE IDT COMMUNITY CAN
EXPERIENCE INDEPENDENCE LIKE
NEVER BEFORE AND THEY CAN BE
AN INCREDIBLE PART OF WHAT
MAKES A COMMUNITY BEAUTIFUL
ON A WHOLE SO TONIGHT OR TODAY
THIS EVENING I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE AND I'M ANXIOUS TO HEAR
FROM OUR PRESENTERS AS WELL AS
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU WELL GOOD
EVENING I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HEATH FLORA REPRESENTING THE
TWELFTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH IS STANISLAUS COUNTY SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY JUST RIGHT OVER
THE HILL SO IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE OVER WITH MY DEAR COLLEAGUES
AT JIM'S TO GRAYSON MISTER LOW
AND THIS PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
IS SOMETHING THAT -- WAS WELL
THE FASTING THINGS WHEN I
GOT ELECTED TWO YEARS AGO I'M
GOING INTO MY SECOND TERM HERE
-- JUST HOW LITTLE OF THIS
COMMUNITY GETS OUT OF THE STATE
AND IT'S FASCINATING TO ME
BECAUSE WHAT BETWEEN THE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS QUITE FRANKLY
SOME OF THE BEST OF US IT'S
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE TO
GET TO KNOW THEM TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE AND
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE
TO FIGHT FOR THEM YOU KNOW I
HAVE A OF A YOUNG GIRL THAT
-- GOT A FEW LITTLE HEARING
SPEECH ISSUES AND WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW SHE GETS THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED BECAUSE WE PUT
THE MONEY IN NOW HER REST OF
HER LIFE CAN BE A MUCH MUCH
DIFFERENT PLACE -- THAT I
REALIZE HOW MUCH AND HOW LITTLE
THE STATE GIVES OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS AS RELATES TO THESE
KIDDOS SO IT'S REALLY SOMETHING
THAT WERE FIGHTING FOR IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE WITH YOU IT'S
AN HONOR TO SERVE AND REPRESENT
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION THANK YOU
AND GET A GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS EVAN LOW AND I REPRESENT SAN
JOSE SILICON VALLEY I WANT TO
FIRST OFF THINK -- ARE CHAIR
FOR HIS EFFORTS IN ENSURING
THAT WE HAD DELIVER FOR THESE
RESPECTIVE ISSUES AS YOU WELL
WELL WELL HERE I CAN IMAGINE IS
THAT SAID THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH
FUNDING AND WE OFTENTIMES SAY
THAT THE STATE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE AND HOLD US EQUALLY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE NEED TO DELIVER
FOR -- AND THAT IT REQUIRES
YOUR CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT SO
PLEASE INTERPRET THAT AS A
CALL TO ACTION ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUALLY DELIVER -- FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE MENTION
PARTICULARLY FOR THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
THERE'S ORGANIZATION THAT
THAT OUR CHAIRS WELL FAMILIAR
WITH FRIENDS OF CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND UNDERSERVED
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSPECTIVE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
AND THE RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY
TO TARGET THESE COMMUNITIES
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT AND SO
I THINK OUR OUR REGION OF
CHAIRMAN FOR ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT AND WOULD VERY MUCH
WELCOME YOUR EXPERTISE AND
DELIVERING AND ENSURING THAT
WE ARE HELD TO ACCOUNT ON THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST I JUST HAVE TO SAY
HOW THANKFUL I AM FOR ALL OF
YOUR PARTICIPATION THESE GUYS
ARE REALLY TRUE CHAMPIONS IN
CAUCUS AND ON THE FLOOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE I THANK ALL OF YOU
ENOUGH THAT FROM THE BOTTOM
OF MY HEART THAT YOU'RE HERE
SO LET'S GET READY TO RUMBLE
LET'S GET STARTED OUR FIRST
GUEST THIS EVENING IS MISS LISA
CLIMB UP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL CENTER EAST BAY THE
REGIONAL SERIES BIG COORDINATE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
FAMILY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN THE ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES MS FIVE
OF THIRTY FIVE AN AMBER THE
SLIDE SIR GONNA BE PROJECTED
YEAH OKAY WELL I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND TELL YOU
BOTH ABOUT THE REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE SYSTEM AS WELL AS ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE ALL
FACE AT THIS TIME THAT REALLY
DO AFFECT THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE REGIONAL CENTER OF THE
EAST THAT THE SITES WILL COME
SHORT ON THE REGIONAL CENTER
OF THESE SPACERS ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WE ARE ONE
OF TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA WE WERE THE LAST
REGIONAL CENTER CREATED IN
THE LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
THE NEXT PICTURE I REALLY
WANT TO SHOW YOU BECAUSE
I THINK WE'RE EXPERIENCING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
YES THAT'S FINE WELL THE
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
WAS ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE
ADVOCACY OF PARENTS IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES WHO FELT
LIKE THERE WERE NO COMMUNITY
SERVICES FOR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THEY REALLY FOUGHT
AND WENT UP TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WEEK AFTER WEEK
AND THEY WORKED WITH FRANKIE
LANDER MEN WHO PASSED LANDER
MEN ACT IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
SIGNED BY GOVERNOR REAGAN AT
THAT TIME AND THE LETTERMAN
ACT REALLY ESTABLISHES THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND BY THE
NINETEEN SURFS THE SEVENTIES
THE -- OTHER ADDITIONS TO THE
LANDER MEN ACT REALLY ESTABLISH
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISEASE
OR LET ME JUST SHARE WITH THE
AUDIENCE THAT YOU HAVE OF WHAT
SHE'S GOING TO BE PRESENTING
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T GET IT
ON THE SCREEN BUT YOU DO HAVE
IT IN THIS FOR CASH TAKE IT SO
-- ARE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE LOCAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS UNDER
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE EACH
REGIONAL CENTER DOES HAVE ITS
OWN CONTRACT WITH THE STATE
BUT IT'S THE SAME BOILERPLATE
CONTRACT OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS
IS FIFTY PERCENT PRIMARY
CONSUMERS OR -- FAMILY MEMBERS
OF CONSUMERS AND IT'S REQUIRED
TO REPRESENT THE ETHNIC
GEOGRAPHIC AND DIVERSITY OF
OUR REGION AND HAVE BOTH LEGAL
MEDICAL AND FINANCIAL EXPERTISE
ON THE BOARD WE ARE SUBJECT
TO ANNUAL FISCAL AUDITS AUDITS
FROM DDS AUDITS ABOUT THE FROM
WAIVERS WE HAVE AND WE ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE A PERFORMANCE
CONTRACT WHICH SAYS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO DURING THE YEAR AND
TERMS OF SERVICE DELIVERY OUR
PRIMARY SERVICE IN MY OPINION
IS CASE MANAGEMENT WE PROVIDE
CASE MANAGEMENT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVE SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS SERVICES AND LEAD
SATISFYING LIFE BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE ALSO MAKE PAYMENTS TO
SERVICE PROVIDERS WEEK MANAGE
PEOPLE'S MONEY THROUGH QUIEN
TRUST WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOING OUT
REACH TO THE BROADER COMMUNITY
ON THE OVERALL ETHNICITY OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER OF THE
EAST BAY REALLY REFLECTS OUR
COMMUNITY AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I'D LIKE TO SAY IS THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT OUR POPULATION
OF CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
THREE AND SEE WHERE WE'RE GOING
THAT POPULATION IS ON RIGHT
NOW IS THIRTY THREE PERCENT
LATINO TWENTY THREE PERCENT
ASIAN SEVENTEEN PERCENT WHITE
SO WE ARE REALLY RESPONSIBLE
TO DEVELOP SERVICES TO
REFLECT WHAT THOSE CULTURAL
AND LINGUISTIC NEEDS ARE --
OUR FUNDING COMES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES BUT IS A COMPLEX MIX
OF BOTH STATE GENERAL FUND AND
FEDERAL DAHLE OURS THE COME
FROM A NUMBER OF WAIVERS AND
OUR REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES
THAT OUR CASE MANAGERS HELP
PEOPLE TO ACCESS CONSIST OF
BOTH SERVICES THAT WE PURCHASE
AS WELL AS WHAT ARE CONSIDERED
GENERIC SERVICES WHICH ARE
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION LIKE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES LIKE MEDICAL
INSURANCE AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS WE HAVE AN EARLY
START PROGRAM WHICH SERVES
CHILDREN FROM ZERO TO THREE AND
CHILDREN WHO HAVE -- HIGH RISK
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE ARE DIAGNOSED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND
WE ARE MANDATED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THOSE CHILDREN
SEARCHES THERAPY -- INFANT
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES EQUIPMENT
ALL OF THOSE KIND OF THINGS
WERE MOSTLY IN THAT REALM AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICE AFTER THE
AGE OF THREE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR ELIGIBILITY DO CHANGE
AND THAT'S A HARD TRANSITION
POINT FOR MANY FAMILIES MANY
WHO WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE
OVER THE AGE OF THREE FOR OUR
SERVICES BUT AFTER THE AGE
OF THREE THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
CEREBRAL PALSY AUTISM EPILEPSY
OR CONDITION REAL CLOSELY
RELATED TO INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AS WELL AS HAVING
A SUBSTANTIAL DISABILITY THE
DIAGNOSIS OF A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY OCCURS BEFORE THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AND THEN I'VE PROVIDED
IN THE BACK EXAMPLES OF THE
SERVICES WE PROVIDE FOR PEOPLE
FROM AGE THREE TO TWENTY TWO
FOR CHILDREN IN THAT AGE GROUP
ARE PRIMARY SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE ACCESS OUR RESPITE
SPECIALIZED DAYCARE ASSISTANCE
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTANCE WITH
COPAYS FOR DIFFERENT INSURANCE
PROVIDER SERVICES VERY FEW
LIVING OPTIONS SERVICES AND
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
FOR THOSE OVER THE AGE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN WE ALSO PROVIDE
FOR ADULTS MOBILITY SERVICES
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
RESPITE THOSE TYPES OF SERVICES
I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL THE
HALLMARK OF HOW WE DEVELOP
SERVICES IS THROUGH PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING AND WE
ARE REALLY LAUNCHED IN THIS
COMMUNITY ON REALLY TRAINING
AND OUTREACH -- WITH OUR
CASE MANAGERS AND OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS WERE ALL REALLY
ENGAGED IN LEARNING MORE ABOUT
THE THE CRITICAL ASPECTS OF
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING AND
DOING THAT BETTER WHERE WE
LISTEN TO WHAT FAMILIES NEED
THE OTHER COMPLEXITY THAT HAS
HAPPENED FOR US OVER THE YEARS
IS ACCESSING GENERIC RESOURCES
WHICH ARE A MAJOR PART OF WHAT
WE WE WORK ON WITH FAMILIES HAS
GOTTEN MORE COMPLEX FAMILIES
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME ACCESSING
THE SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY WE
TRACE CHALLENGES WITH ACTUALLY
GETTING IN THE DOOR OF SYSTEMS
WHICH FACED DISCRIMINATION
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH YOU DON'T MOSTLY AMONG
PRIMARILY WON'T SERVE OUR
POPULATION OF OUR EAST BAY
COMMUNITY IS A VERY STRONG
COMMUNITY OUR STRENGTHS ARE WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES COUNCIL IN
BOTH COUNTIES WHICH WERE
ESTABLISHED DURING THE KENNEDY
ERA -- WE HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT
FIRST FOCUS COMMUNITY WE
HAVE REPLICATED IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY A MODEL FOR DELIVERING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND WE
HAVE A COMMUNITY THAT FINDS
COMMON GROUND TO STRENGTHEN
OUR ADVOCACY AND DIVERSITY
IS REALLY A STRENGTH IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING NEW RESOURCES ON
OUR LOCAL CHALLENGES SIMILAR
TO WHAT I HEARD AND FRESNO
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING WERE
HIGH COST AREA FOR WORKERS
WE HAVE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES
THAT ARE NOT MET BY THIS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED
BI LINGUAL THERAPIST AND OTHER
STAFF WHO ARE NOT READILY
AVAILABLE AND PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT ON MEDIAN RATES WERE
IMPOSED ON REGIONAL CENTERS
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE COULD
PAY PROVIDERS -- PROVIDERS
HAD TO MEET A UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE -- WERE IT TAPPED
THE BILLING WAS IMPOSED ON
PROVIDERS TO BILL CHILDREN
WHO WERE ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
START WERE LIMITED -- WE LOST
FLEXIBILITY ANNUAL FAMILY
PROGRAM FEES WERE IMPOSED ON
THERE WAS INCREASE RELIANCE
ON INSURANCE AND FOR MANY
PEOPLE ELIMINATION OF SOCIAL
RECREATION CAMPING WAS A REALLY
BIG DEAL OF THE FAST -- AND OUR
CHALLENGES AS A REGIONAL CENTER
OR WE HAVE A FUNDING FORMULA
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS THAT IS
ANTIQUATED DATES BACK TO THE
EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
EARLY NINETIES WE STATE WIDE
NEED MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MORE CASE WORKERS TO MEET
OUR CASELOAD RAY FEELS WE --
HAVE THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
ABILITY TO DEVELOP NEW SERVICES
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT HAVE
FUNDING FOR START UP FOR THE
COMMUNITY SO OUR PROVIDERS ARE
CLOSING BECAUSE THEY'RE UNABLE
TO RETAIN STAFF AND UNABLE
TO EXPAND THE GROWTH THERE IS
GROWTH IN POPULATION BUT NOT
AVAILABLE SERVICES THERE'S A
HIGH TURNOVER OF DIRECT SERVICE
STAFF AND THAT MEANS LESS
TRAINING AND PUTS VULNERABLE
PEOPLE AT RISK WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT KIND OF TALK TURN OVER
AND WE CAN'T MEET THE PROMISES
IN THE I PP AND I'LL TELL YOU
QUICKLY WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WE NEED TO END MEDIAN RATES WE
NEED TO ALLOW REGIONAL CENTERS
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET LOCAL NEEDS
WE NEED TO INCREASE PROVIDER
RATE TO REFLECT THE AREA COSTS
AND ALLOW FOR ADJUSTMENT NGUYEN
MINIMUM WAGES COME IN AS IN
THE MUNICIPALITY WE NEED TO
RESTORE SOCIAL RECREATION AND
CAMPING WE NEED TO ELIMINATE
THE ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM FEE
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE A
HALF DAY BILLING AND WE NEED TO
UPDATE REGIONAL CENTER FUNDING
FORMULAS TO REFLECT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REALITIES AND LASTLY
I'LL SAY IN OUR COMMUNITY WE
LOOK A COLLABORATION SO WE
NEED TO KEEP THE DOLLARS THAT
HAVE BEEN SAVED BY CLOSING
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN OUR
SYSTEM WE NEED TO SUPPORT
INITIATIVES TO ADDRESS HOUSING
NEEDS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE NEED TO RESTORE FUNDING
FOR NEWS START A PROGRAM OF
NEW PROGRAMS AND WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN EVERY COUNTY
SERVE PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO ARE ACTUALLY
AT HIGHER RISK OF HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THANK YOU
REASON THERE MAY BE SOME
QUESTIONS FROM -- MY COLLEAGUES
-- I'LL START WITH THE MISTER
LOWER IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE EXACT QUICKER I I DO
I DO IF IF I IF I MY DAD JUST
VERY IT AS CONCISE AS POSSIBLE
YOU OUTLINED A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS WHICH IS
GREAT -- MIGHT YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS ON THE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR THAT WELL I
THINK THAT THE RATE STUDY THAT
IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW FOR OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE NEED TO
FULLY FUND AND MAYBE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE RATE STUDY MAYBE
WILL THINK WE NEED MORE IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
HIGH COST COMMUNITIES I ALSO
THINK THAT THE STATE NEEDS
TO FUND SERVICE COORDINATORS
AT A REALISTIC WAY TO
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE FUNDED AT
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR SERVICE
COORDINATOR WE CANNOT HIRE
SOMEONE TO PROVIDE THE KIND
OF SERVICES THAT PEOPLE NEED
MISSED FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THANK IS PROBABLY JUST MORE
OF A COMMA BUT IN YOUR FIRST
DOWN BULLET ITEM HERE ON YOUR
CLEVER SOLUTIONS YOU TO KEEP
IN THE DOLLARS FROM CLOSED
A CENTERS I'VE HEARD THAT A
COUPLE TIMES JUST TONIGHT AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
AWESOME THAT IS HERE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT -- I COULD GET
PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT FIGHT FOR
BECAUSE THOSE NUMBERS THOSE
DOLLARS ARE ALREADY THERE
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP THEM HERE
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S AS FAR
AS LOW HANGING FRUIT SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN BE WORKED OUT GREAT
RESTORATION YES ARE THERE AREAS
THAT YOU'VE NOTICED WHERE OTHER
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS OR PROVIDERS
WERE THERE SEEMS TO BE RE DONE
AND SEE WHERE WE IF WE WERE
TO CONSOLIDATE OR BRING SOME
SCHOOLS SOURCES TOGETHER -- WE
COULD GET INSTEAD OF A SPRAY
WE GET A LASER AND BECOME A
BIT MORE PRODUCTIVE HAVE YOU
IDENTIFIED IN THE THOSE ARE
IS IN YOUR FIELD WELL WHAT
OUT WHAT I'LL SAY IS THAT I DO
THINK THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
WITH FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CARE CENTERS TO HELP WITH ON
HEALTH CARE NEEDS WHERE THE
SERVICES ARE CONCENTRATED IN
ONE PLACE WITH PEOPLE WITH
SPECIALTY KNOWLEDGE -- BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT MANY PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO THEIR LOCAL
HEALTH CLINIC AND BE ABLE TO
GET THE SERVICES WHERE EVERYONE
ELSE DOES SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF NEED FOR MORE TRAINING
MORE EXPERTISE OIL ALL OVER THE
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE RUN ACROSS IN KIND OF THE
TRAVELS AND TALKING TO SOME
OF THE MEMBERS THE POPULATION
IS SOME KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE HEALTH PLANS IN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS WORD YOU'RE
THE ADVOCATE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
TO THE HEALTH PLANS JUST
SEEMS LIKE WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT YOU TELL THEM THAT IN
IDENTIFIED THAT THEY HAVE AN
ABILITY TO GO TO THEIR HEALTH
PLAN BUT THEN IT'S JUST A KIND
OF A -- HAND OFTEN NO REAL
ADVOCACY AT THAT AFTER THAT
POINT CAN WE LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE UP FACILITATED
AND I KNOW IT'S SOME IT'S
ABOUT IT MANPOWER AND ONE BUT
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IF WE HAVE
A SINGLE PARENT WHO'S TRYING
TO STAY OF OF FLOAT WITH THEIR
EMPLOYMENT DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE ALL OF THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT HEALTH PLANS
HAVE ALSO AND SO I'M LOOKING
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT ALSO
BECAUSE RIGHT SERIOUSLY I
AGREE I THINK THERE ARE SO MANY
LAYERS OF GENERIC RESOURCES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO ACCESS IT'S
AN INCREDIBLY COMPLEX SITUATION
AS IS PRIVATE INSURANCE SO I'D
LOVE TO WORK ON THE ISSUE WE
DEVELOPED A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH CONTRA COSTA HEALTH PLAN
AS WE TRANSITION PEOPLE FROM
AB A FUNDED BY REGIONAL CENTERS
TO AB A FUNDED THROUGH THE
HEALTH PLANS BUT THAT WAS THE
ONE HEALTH PLAN THE REALLY DID
AN OUTSTANDING JOB NOT OLD DID
AS WELL AND IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
HAPPEN SO I I WOULD LIKE TO
WORK ON THE ISSUE BUT IT WILL
TAKE CASE MANAGEMENT RATIOS
ARE OTHER WAYS OF SERVING
PEOPLE AND GETTING ACCESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW RETENTION
OF EMPLOYMENT FOR YOUR THROUGH
YOUR FOLKS AND AND HAVING
AN ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF CASE
MANAGERS YES MOVING FORWARD OF
WHEN YOU HAVE OF YOUR PROVIDERS
IS MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S
A WAITING LIST BECAUSE OF OF
-- BASICALLY THE WAY THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED THE RESOURCES HALF
THE BUILDING THE THE FURLOUGHS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO WE'RE
LOSING PROVIDERS AND NOW THE
CLIENTS ARE COSTS CONSUMERS
ARE BEING MADE TO WAIT YES
ACTION ACTUALLY WHY A MET WITH
A SERVICE PROVIDER YESTERDAY
WHO TOLD ME THAT EVERY TIME
HE HAS A CONSUMER LEAVE HIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY MOVE
FOR OTHER THINGS HAPPEN HE
CANNOT FILL THAT SLOT BECAUSE
HE STILL DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
STAFFING SO IT'S ALMOST LIKE
THIS BECAUSE OF THE RATES AND
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMY IN THIS
AREA HE JUST CAN'T TAKE ON IN
THE PEOPLE EVEN TO BACK FILL
SOME SLUTTY USED TO HAVE A
PROGRAM GERMANY NUMBERS ON HOW
MANY CONSUMERS YOU HAVE WAITING
FOR SERVICES YOU KNOW THAT'S A
HARD THING TO LOOK AT BECAUSE
I THINK SOME PEOPLE HAVE
GIVEN UP A LITTLE BIT BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE COULD
LOOK AT WE DID HAVE SOME DAY
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO LOOKED
AT HOW MANY PEOPLE THEY HAD
ON THEIR WAITING LIST BUT IT'S
A LITTLE OFF BECAUSE PEOPLE
CAN BE ON MULTIPLE WAITING
LESSON OF THE OTHER THING IS
IT WOULD WOULD HELP VALIDATE
YEAH THE RATE STUDY IN AND THE
NEED TO ENABLE TO SUPPORT IT
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH
ONE TWO OR ABA PROVIDER IN
THE AREA WHICH IS KRISTIN
BREA ISSUES -- WITH THE CENTER
OF SOCIAL DYNAMICS CHRISTIAN
PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK SO HI MY NAME IS KRISTEN
BREA I'VE BEEN IN THE FIELD OF
-- INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FOR ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS TWENTY NINE YEARS --
TWENTY FIVE THAT WAS AS A
CLINICIAN WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
FAMILIES AND CLIENTS GOINGS
THE HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY INTO
SCHOOL SETTINGS WHEN IT OFF
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY AROSE NOW
I'M IN THE -- DUBIOUS HONOR OF
BEING IN THE AT THE ADMIN SIDE
OF IT SOME REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR A COMPANY THAT PROVIDES ABA
SERVICES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND OREGON AND WASHINGTON
COMPANIES CALLED CENTER FOR
SOCIAL SOCIAL DYNAMICS I
RUN OFFICES IN ROHNERT PARK
VALLEJO AND -- SACRAMENTO --
BUT WE DO ALSO HAVE AN OFFICE
HERE IN ALAMEDA WE'RE OPENING
ONE CERTAIN MARTINEZ WERE
DEFINITELY COVER IN THIS AREA
AS WELL SO DOES YOU KNOW HOW
FOR A BA SERVICES I'LL GIVE
YOU A LITTLE -- JUST A QUICK
ABA ABA IS APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS IT'S SCIENCE BASED
THERAPY WORKING ON BEHAVES OF
CHILDREN OUR CLIENTS ANY AGE SO
WE GO INTO THE HOMES WE TALK TO
THE PARENTS WE FIND OUT THEIR
CONCERNS WE REALLY GET A SENSE
OF WHAT WOULD IMPROVE THEIR
LIVES THE QUALITY OF THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR CHILD'S LIVES
WE DO YOU USE ASSESSMENT TOOLS
AND WE COME UP WITH A VERY
INDIVIDUALIZED PROGRAM FOR THAT
CLIENT SO WHAT WE'RE FACING
NOW THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
AND IT'S FAIRLY RECENT WITH
THE INSURANCE PAYERS IS THERE
TRYING TO AGE OUT OUR CLIENTS
HAD A MUCH YOUNGER AGE WE'RE
GETTING AUTHORIZED FOR LESS
HOURS AND WERE HAVING TO
FIGHT HARDER FOR THOSE HOURS
SO TYPICALLY WE WOULD GET
ANYWHERE FROM THIRTEEN AND A
HALF TO FIFTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
HOURS A MONTH IS A SUPER IS
LEVEL NOW ALL THE REPORTS THAT
WERE SUBMITTING THEIR OWN AND
ONLY APPROVING SIX SO IT'S
REALLY LIMITING WHAT WE CAN
DO FOR THOSE CLIENTS AND FOR
THE AGING OUT PROCESS YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST WE DISAGREE WITH
THAT STRONGLY AND ARE REALLY
HAVING TO PUSH BACK IN ORDER
TO CONTINUE SERVICES IT'S VERY
DATABASE THE A BA AND SO WE
HAVE WE HAVE THE RATIONALE THE
CLINICAL RATIONALE AND WE HAVE
THE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE QUALITY THE LIVES OF THE
CLIENTS AND FOR THE FAMILIES
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE IN THIS AND
FOR THEM TO BE PUSHING BACK
AND LIMITING THOSE ANY CHILD
OVER THE AGE OF FIFTEEN THEY
NOW WANT TO TRANSITION PLAN
SOME OF THESE CLIENTS WE DON'T
GET INTO THEIR FOURTEEN AND SO
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN GIVE
A TRANSITION PLAN SO THAT'S OUR
BIGGEST STRUGGLE RIGHT NOW THE
OTHER THING IS IS -- COPAYS OF
THE BIG ONE SO WE HAVE FAMILIES
WHO ARE UNABLE TO RECEIVE OUR
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE COPAYS
ATTACHED TO THAT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT WE MIGHT HAVE
A CLIENT THAT RECEIVE SERVICES
FIVE DAYS A WEEK THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE FAMILY PAY THE CO PAY
FOR EVERY TIME WE'RE IN THE
HOME CASE THAT'S A STRUGGLE
AND SCHISM FAMILIES REFUSE
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THAT WE
DO NOT WANT TO SEE THAT THAT
BREAKS OUR HEARTS THE OWNER
OF THE COMPANY THAT I WORK FOR
HAS CREATED A FOUNDATION AND
WE'RE AS WE FUNDRAISE FOR THAT
FOUNDATION WHICH IS SEPARATE
FROM THE ACTUAL COMPANY YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE USED FORCE
TO HELP FAMILIES A CO PAYS OKAY
WE WANT TO FIND SOLUTIONS AND
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS
OR TRYING TO CREATE OUR OWN --
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE WORRY ABOUT WITH OUR CLIENTS
IS AS THE -- AS THEIR A TRYING
TO AGE OUT OUR CLIENTS AT A
VERY EARLY AGE WE HAD A MEETING
RECENTLY AND ONE OF THE PAIRS
REPRESENTED THE PAIR SAID TO
US EVERY CLIENT OVER THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN SHOULD BE SERVICED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTERS BUT IT'S
SUCH A FAR CRY FROM THE REALITY
THAT WE FACE EVERY DAY EVERY
DAY WE SEE PARENTS WHO ARE
DENIED SERVICES FROM REGIONAL
CENTERS I SEE INCONSISTENCIES
FROM ONE REGIONAL CENTER TO
ANOTHER AND WE WORK WITH SO
MANY AND IN THE REGION I COVER
A LOAN AND SOME ARE GREAT
AND AND THE CLIENTS ARE ARE
GETTING THOSE CO PAY ASSISTANCE
AND THEY'RE GETTING RESPITE
SERVICES AND OTHER ONES ARE
DENIED -- SUMMER DENIED BECAUSE
THEY DENY THEIR DIAGNOSIS WHEN
THE DIAGNOSIS ACTUALLY CAME
FROM THE INSURANCE COMPANY DOWN
WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT SOMETIMES A
CLAIM IS DENIED BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONSIDERED NOT IMPACTED ENOUGH
WHEN WE KNOW BECAUSE WE WORK
WITH THAT PLAN THAT WE CAN'T
EVEN TAKE THAT CLIENT INTO
THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT BEING
A HARNESS PHYSICALLY BECAUSE
IT'S SUCH A DANGER OKAY SO IT
DOESN'T DOESN'T MAKE SENSE --
SOME OF THE THINGS WE'VE REALLY
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH DEFINITELY
IN CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHICS IS A
COMBINATION OF DUAL DIAGNOSIS
SO WE USED WE ARE TRAINED TO
DEAL WITH AUTISM BUT WE'RE
GETTING SO MANY EXPRESSLY WITH
OUR YOUNGER TEENS THAT HAVE
A DUAL DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE
ARE NOT TRAINED TO WORK WITH
THOSE KIDS BUT WE WILL NOT
NOT SERVICE THOSE KIDS WILL
DO OUR BEST BUT WHEN WE MEET
WITH THE INSURANCE COMPANY
HAVE A CLINICAL CONSULTATION
AND EXPLAIN OUR SERVICES
ARE NOT HELPING THIS CLIENT
THEY MAY BE HEARING VOICES
THEY MAY BE HAVING ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT'S NOT A
BE A SERVICES BUT THE CLINIC
THE CLINICAL TEAM FROM THE
INSURANCE PAYER WILL COME BACK
AT US AND SAY YOU'RE THE ONLY
OPTION YOU'RE ALL THAT THERE
IS FOR THE FAMILY WE'VE GONE
THROUGH EVERYTHING ELSE WELL WE
WON'T STOP PROVIDING SERVICES
BECAUSE WE WANT THE FAMILY DOWN
SO WE STILL GO IN THERE EVERY
DAY NOT NECESSARILY HAVING THE
KNOWLEDGE OR THE TRAINING TO
TO REALLY HELP WE DO THE BEST
THAT WE CAN WE HAVE FAMILIES
THAT WILL DENY SERVICES
BECAUSE -- OF DIFFERENT CUSTOMS
YOU KNOW SO DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT CULTURES HAVE THEIR
VERY DIFFERENT BELIEFS AND
SOMETIMES THERE'S A SHAME WITH
A DIAGNOSIS AND FAMILIES WON'T
LET US INTO THE HOMES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THE NEIGHBORS
WITH OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
OR FRIENDS TO KNOW THERE'S
ANYTHING WRONG HOW DO WE REACH
THOSE FAMILIES HOW DO WE BRIDGE
THAT HOW DO WE EMPOWER THOSE
FAMILIES WELL BEING CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE TOOK KNOWLEDGE
THE BENEFIT THAT WE CAN GET
WE HAVE CERTAIN CULTURES
THAT ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
ON ACADEMICS AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE FOR TRYING
TO TEACH THEIR CHILD TO HAVE
RECIPROCAL CONVERSATION SO THEY
CAN INTERACT WITH PEERS AND
COLLEAGUES LATER IN LIFE HOW
DO WE EDUCATE THE PARENTS ARE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I IT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT AS WERE AGING
IS CLIENTS OUT IS WHERE DO THEY
GO YOU KNOW THE PAIR JUST SAYS
THE FAMILIES NEED TO FIGURE IT
OUT IT'S NOT FAIR THE FAMILIES
AND THAT'S NOT HOW WE DO THINGS
OF THE COMPANY WE WILL NOT
LET THIS PARENTS STRUGGLE WILL
DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
WE'RE NOT CASE MANAGERS SO
HOW DO WE GET MORE KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT WHAT IS AVAILABLE AT THE
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS IN
THE DIFFERENT LEVELS IN THE
RESOURCES FOR THOSE FAMILIES IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE SERVICES FOR
THEM EVEN IF WE CAN'T BE THE
ONES TO DO IT SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE ON A DAILY BASIS I THINK
A LOT OF IT IS GOING TO COME
DOWN TO FUNDING AND IT'S GOING
TO BE THE REGIONAL CENTERS WE
HAVE THE ANSWERS FOR THAT YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE THEIR SET UP
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE MONEY TO DO THAT FOR OUR
CLIENTS AND WE NEED TO BRIDGES
YOU WERE DISCUSSING EARLIER THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN THINGS LIKE ABA
SERVICES AND REGIONAL CENTERS
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE BRIDGE
THAT GAP BECAUSE THERE'S A HUGE
ALL RIGHT NOW THERE'S A HUGE
ASSUMPTION FROM THE PAYERS THE
INSURANCE PAIRS THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TAKING OVER AND THAT'S
NOT THAT'S NOT HAPPENING SO
HOW DO WE MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
IT ALL COMES DOWN TO FUNDING
YOU KNOW -- THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH HOW I HAD YEAH MR LOW ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE STRIP K.
FLOOR I DON'T GET IT THIS
GRAYSON JUST REAL QUICK --
ON YOUR LAST POINT HOW WOULD
FUNDING JUST GIVE ME AN IDEA
HOW WOULD FUNDING HOPE THAT
TRIP -- THE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN AB SERVICES AND
REGIONAL CENTERS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW FOR NOT UNDERSTANDING
ALL THE THINGS THE REGIONAL
SERVICES OFFER AND I THINK
THEY DON'T ALWAYS VOLUNTEER
THAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO PROVIDE SO I THINK BY
INCREASING THE FUNDING BILL
INCREASE THE ABILITY AND WEEK
THEY CAN BETTER ADVERTISEMENT
THESE PARENTS KNOW WHAT IS
AVAILABLE AND I THINK THEY'LL
BE MORE CONSISTENCY IF THEY
HAVE MORE FUNDS THEY COULD BE
MORE CONSISTENT FROM REGIONAL
CENTER REGIONAL CENTER TO WHAT
THEY OFFER I JUST ATHLETES THAT
DOES THE REGIONAL CENTER HELP
COVER COPAYS AND SHE SAID YES
AND I SAID MY CLIENTS AREN'T
GETTING THAT AND SHE SAID IT'S
NOT FROM THIS AREA IS IT AND
I SAID NO MY CLIENTS ARE FROM
SOLANO COUNTY NAPA COUNTY AND
THE REGIONAL CENTER THERE HAS
NOT BEEN COVERING THAT SO HOW
DO WE GET CONSISTENCY WELL
MAYBE IF THEY HAVE MORE FUNDING
THEY'LL IMPLEMENT THAT OCT
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT YOU
BEING A SERVICE PROVIDER ARE
YOU WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTERS WE ARE
WORKING WITH A COUPLE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO GET BEEN DRIES VÀ THROUGH --
NORTH BAY REGIONAL CENTER AND
IT HASN'T HAPPENED FOR REASONS
THAT I'M NOT SURE BECAUSE I'M
NOT PART OF THAT PROCESS SO IS
THERE WE CAN FOLLOW UP ON THAT
AFTER THE AFTER THE -- MEETING
BUT SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS
YOU'RE YOU'RE READY WILLING AND
ABLE TO GO DO AND IF THERE'S
A WAITING LIST THE NORTH BAY
HAS WE HAVE A WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TAKE THOSE CLIENTS
WE HAVE THE REALLY I HAVE THE
ABILITY IT'S MY JOB TO GROW
THE COMPANY AND I HAVE THAT
ABILITY AND WE ABSOLUTELY WANT
THOSE CLIENTS NOW SOMETIMES
THE PAY RATES ARE AN ISSUE AND
THAT DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT BUT YES I HAVE THE
ABILITY BECAUSE CLIENTS WE HAVE
LIKE ABA COMPANY DO NOT HAVE
A WAITING LIST WE DON'T TAKE
CLIENTS UNLESS WE CAN PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES WE NEVER SAY
NO AND PLEASE SAID MENTION
SOMETHING ABOUT LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND AND YOU TOUCHED
ON THE CULTURAL ISSUES BUT
-- THE THE LANGUAGE BARRIERS
AND AND THE -- HERE IMMIGRANT
STATUS KIND OF HAS BEEN A AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM IN
THE PAST HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
THE -- THE IMMIGRANT OF WHO
IS AFRAID OF BEING DEPORTED
OR OF OF RECEIVING SERVICES
WE HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF THAT
BECAUSE IN ORDER I THINK THEY
HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY BE A CERTAIN
SHOW SOMETHING TO GET THE
INSURANCE BECAUSE UNLESS THEY
HAVE INSURANCE THEY DON'T COME
TO US -- I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
HAD FAMILIES THAT HAVE HAD TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY THEIR CHILD
WAS OF AMERICAN CITIZEN BUT
THEY WERE NOT THEIR CHILD DID
HAVE COVERAGE RECEIVE SERVICES
BUT THEN THEY HAD TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY AND TAKE THE CHILD
WITH THEM SO YEAH WE DO FACE
THAT WAS RISEN THANK YOU CHAIR
IDEA -- I WILL GO BACK TO THE
QUESTION OF MY COLLEAGUE ASKED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW OF FOR
THE FIRST PRESENTER IS THERE
AN AREA WHERE YOU SEE FUNDING
THAT COULD BE BETTER USED IN
OTHER WORDS HOW DO YOU SEE THE
FUNDING OR WHERE DO YOU SEE
THE FUNDING COMING FROM I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF HOW YOU AS IS
-- IS THERE AN AREA WHERE YOU
SEE FUNDING NOT BEING USED AT
ITS MOST EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
WAY THAT YOU THINK IF WE RE
DIRECTED IT IT WOULD BE BETTER
HONESTLY NO I DON'T BUT THEN
I'M VERY I'M LIMITED MORE
LIMITED IN THE ABA COMMUNITY OR
ALL THE MONEY TYPICALLY COMES
FROM OF THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
DOUBT BUT I DEFINITELY ALSO IN
TOUCH ON THE FACT THAT SO MUCH
OF WHAT SOME OF OUR CLIENTS YOU
KNOW THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION THAT
FROM THE PAYERS THAT THERE ARE
GROUP HOMES AND THERE ARE DAY
PROGRAMS AND THEIR JOB TRAINING
FOR THESE CLIENTS AND THERE'S
NOT THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO SEE
A LOT MORE THE FUNDING GO --
IT BREAKS MY HEART WHEN I HAVE
TO CONVINCE ONE OF MY CLIENTS
TO BE OKAY WITH SWEEPING FLOORS
WHEN THEY WERE DETERMINED WHEN
THEY WENT OUT IN THE JOB MARKET
THEY'RE GONNA BE WORKING IN
TECH OR VIDEO GAMES YOU KNOW
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES AREN'T
THERE I DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN THAT DAYS BE BIG CHANGE
AND JOB TRAINING MR LOOK AT
I THINK THAT'S A PART OF THE
COMMENTS IN THE OBSERVATION
THAT WE RELY ON INDIVIDUALS
LIKE YOURSELVES TO PROVIDE US
YOUR INSIGHTS IN A LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE TO HELP US IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL REVENUES BECAUSE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE HAVE
COMPETING INTERESTS I JUST CAME
BACK FROM ANOTHER FUNCTION IN
WHICH A SPEAKING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ASSIMILATE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH MONEY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THESE VARIOUS ISSUES
HOW DO WE LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL
REVENUES -- AND OR EXISTING
REVENUES TO BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND SERVING -- SIGNIFICANT
POPULATIONS AND THINK THAT'S
THE MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION
THAT WE WANT TO COLLECTIVELY
AS A WHOLE ONE TO -- IS TRY TO
SOLVE AND AND DO THIS TOGETHER
AS WELL EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO
I JUST HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION
OR SO WE HAVE AN I.
E.
P.
WE HAVE AN I PP SERVICE
PROVIDERS DOING A COMPONENT
OF OF THE APA BUT WE ALSO HAVE
THE EDUCATIONAL DO YOU BELIEVE
IN YOUR EXPERIENCES THAT THE
THE PROVIDERS AND THE SCHOOLS
SHOULD ACTUALLY COME TOGETHER
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF THAT
CHILD SUCCESS ABSOLUTELY I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP THAT'S A HUGE STRUGGLE THAT
WE HAVE -- THE SCHOOLS FEEL
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN THE
HOME SETTING AND WE'RE TRYING
TO CREATE ALL THESE SKILLS IN
THE CHILD WOULD MAKE SENSE THAT
WE SHOULD GO INTO THE SCHOOL
SETTING TO SEE WHERE THEY
STRUGGLE THEY'RE AN OFFER THE
SAME SERVICES BUT IF THE THIS
PAY YOUR SAY THAT IF THE CHILD
HAS AN IEP WE'RE NOT ALLOWED
IN THE SCHOOL SETTING AND YOU
KNOW IT AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
SCHOOLS AREN'T THEY THEY FEEL
THE SCHOOLS TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING WHATEVER'S IN
THAT I YOU PETE -- THE REALITY
IS THOSE KIDS ARE GETTING
SUPPORT THEY NEED MOST OF
OUR CLIENTS STRUGGLE THE MOST
OF BEING BULLIED AT DURING
RECESS AND DURING LUNCH TIME
AND DURING PEAK FOR SUMMER
OLDER ONES THOSE ARE THE MOST
THERE'S A TIMES A STRUGGLE
THE MOST SO SOMETIMES WE CAN
KIND OF PLAY LET'S MAKE A
DEAL WITH THE PAIR AND SAY WE
ONLY GO FOR FORTY FIVE MINUTES
DURING UNSTRUCTURED SCHOOL
TIME CAN WE GO IN THERE AND
ASSIST THEM CAN WE HELP FORGE
SOME PEER INTERACTIONS CAN
WE TEACH THEM SOME POSITIVE
-- PEER INTERACTIONS YOU KNOW
AND BUILD THAT UP FOR THEM AND
EVERYONE SO WHILE WE GET IN
THERE PARENTS OFTEN REQUEST
THAT WE GO TO THE I.
E.
P.
A SUPPORT FOR THEM IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE FOR CONTINUING OF
SERVICES TO BE ABLE TO HEAR HOW
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO SCHOOL
SETTING SEE WHERE THE STRUGGLE
IS BRING THOSE INTO THE HOME
TO WORK ON AND THEN GENERALIZE
AND OTHER SETTINGS AND IT'S
JUST TOO HARD TO GET IN THERE
THEY JUST WON'T LET US YEAH
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST HANG UP
ON THE ECONOMY SERVICES SEEMS
LIKE A VERY ELEMENTARY THING
THAT THAT I MEAN THROUGHOUT
THIS THAT SHOULD BE LIKE NUMBER
ONE RIGHT I MEAN WE SEE KIDS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THEY GO
TO SCHOOL THEY'RE DOING VERY
WELL IN THE GOING TO ANOTHER
SETTING IN THE FALL OFF THE
TREE OR OR VICE VERSA WHAT IS
THE BIGGEST -- HURDLE TO GET
OVER WHO'S WHO HAS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE WITH THAT IS THAT THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM THEY DON'T WANT
PEOPLE LOOKING UNDER THE TENT
THEY GOT THEIR OWN PROGRAMS
YOU KNOW IT REALLY VARIES FROM
SCHOOL TO SCHOOL SOME SCHOOLS
ARE SO PLEASE THAT WE'RE IN
THERE AND AND JUST WELCOME
US WITH OPEN ARMS AND OTHER
SCHOOLS WILL NOT ALLOW US IN
THERE I HAD I WORKED DIRECTLY
WITH THE CLIENT IN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL IN NAPA AND I WAS ONLY
ALLOWED FOR THIRTY MINUTES AT
A TIME SUPERVISED AND SO THERE
WAS REALLY NOTHING I COULD DO
WITH MY CLIENT THEY AND I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THEIR HANG UP WAS
AND WE'VE WE'VE DEALT WITH THAT
MULTIPLE SCHOOL SINCE THEN --
I THINK MAYBE THEY THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING IN THERE TO SHOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WRONG WHEN
THAT COURSE NOT OUR INTENT AT
ALL WE'RE JUST THERE TO SUPPORT
THE CLIENTS BUT -- YEAH I THINK
I THINK YOU HAVE TO DO THE
PAYER DOES NOT WANT US TO SAY
OR DO ANYTHING REPRESENTING
THEM AND THEY'RE THE ONES
PAYING FOR THE SERVICES I THINK
THAT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH
IT THE SCHOOL YOU KNOW AND THE
PAIR FEELS LIKE THE SCHOOLS BE
RESPONSIBLE IF THERE'S AN AYE
YOU PM PLACE THEY'RE OFF THE
HOOK BECAUSE IT'S THE SCHOOL'S
RESPONSIBILITY WE JUST NOW AS
AND AS FAMILIES NO THIS IS NOT
THE CASE YEAH SO DEALING WITH
IT RIGHT WHEN I JUST THOUGHT
OF ANOTHER ONE -- DEALING WITH
HELP AS A DO THEY HAVE THE
SAME STRUCTURE ON HOW THE --
SERVICE OR ASK YOU TO SERVICE
THE CONSUMER GOING FORWARD
OR IS IT JUST A RUN THE GAMUT
IT VERY MUCH DEPENDS ON THE
PAIR THERE'S DIFFERENT THERE'S
DIFFERENT SO WE'RE SET UP FOR
THE THREE OFFICES IRAN WERE SET
UP FOR THREE TIER SO THERE'S
A MID LEVEL A DIRECT LEVEL
AND A HIGH LEVEL OF SOME SOME
PAIRS ARE ONLY TO TEAR WHICH
REQUIRES A LICENSE CLINICIAN
TO PROVIDE THE MIDLEVEL
SUPERVISION WILL BE C.
B.
A.'S AT THE LICENSE CLINICIAN
WAS ARE HARD TO COME BY AND
A VERY EXPENSIVE SO FOR US
FOR THEM TO BE PROVIDING THE
MIDLEVEL SUPERVISION IN A
SENSE IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
WHICH IS WHY THAT LIMITS US
TO WEB HERE'S WE ACCEPT YEAH
I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
ME HERE TODAY IT HAS BEEN
UP WHAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
FOR IS PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
TRENCHES WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY GIVING US THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AND THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO --
WHAT WE CALL THE SELF ADVOCATES
A WILL SANFORD -- HE'S WITH
THE FEATURES EXPORT OF WORK
WITH WILL FOR MANY YEARS NOW
ON -- DIFFERENT ISSUES -- BOTH
LEGISLATION AND -- HE IS ONE
OF MY GO TO GUYS FOR FOR THIS
-- INFORMATION SO WILL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE PLACE TO BE
HERE -- I'M GONNA TRY TO GET
AWAY AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
BUT THERE'S REALLY THREE MAJOR
ISSUES THAT ARE COMMITTEES TALK
A LOT ABOUT YOU'VE HEARD -- THE
MENTION ALREADY ONE IS DIRECT
PROFESSIONALS OUR ABILITY
TO HIRE AND RETAIN STAFF
-- THERE'S A TOWN HALL LAST
WEEKEND'S -- WHERE THE AVERAGE
ENTRY LEVEL JOB IN OAKLAND IS
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR THE
AVERAGE PAY FOR A RESTAURANT
WORKERS BETWEEN TWELVE AND
FOURTEEN CAN YOU SEE WHY WE
DON'T HAVE RESPITE WORKERS OR
OTHER FOLKS IT AS A HUGE IMPACT
OUR FOLKS THERE TO THE -- BOTH
THE CALL AN HONOR TO TALK ABOUT
OUR HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
IS A BIG THREE UP THERE I
THINK IF I CAN JUMP FORWARD
AND AND KIND OF ONE QUESTION
AT THE END I HATE TO SAY IT
BUT PART OF THE BLAME LIVES IN
A PLACE CALLED SACRAMENTO BIG
WHITE DOME WHERE EVERYTHING IS
FREE TO SILOS INTO THE CENTER
RULES APPLIED EDUCATION THE
SENATE RULES THAT APPLY TO
PART IN A RE AT IS A SET OF
RULES APPLY TO DDS IS SET A
RULES APPLY TO AND COMMUNICATE
LICENSING THEY RARELY IF EVER
TALK AND ARE OFTEN IN DIRECT
CONFLICT SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE LARGEST BERRIES OF OUR
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY CREATE A
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS PEOPLE
VERY EFFECTIVELY SO WITH THAT
I'M NEVER IT INVITE NICOLE
BICE BOTH LOG UP HERE I CAN
ALMOST SO YOU THINK YOU USED
TO SAID THIS FROM ME OVER
ALSO WE GET THIS AND YET MAYBE
WE GOTTA SO MAKE SURE
HE WON'T SAY HOW MUCH
THAT BOX COST YOU COULD
BUY LIKE FOUR DOZEN I
YEAH THAT WOULD
TAKE
SEC TECHNOLOGIST
YEAH LIKE THAT TO THE GYM
ON THE JOB
GOOD EVENING AND HELLO MY
NAME IS NICOLE AND I LIVE
IN ANTIOCH BEFORE I GET
TROLLING NO PUN INTENDED I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A SECOND
TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PHRASE HERE FOR HAVING THIS
EVENT TONIGHT CHAIRING THE
ID DO YOU SELECT COMMITTEE
AND IN GENERAL HAVING A BACKS
WELL HERE I AM AGAIN TO TALK
ABOUT THE SAME DONE THING
THAT IS AFFECTING SO MANY
OF US LATELY TO ME THIS IS
RIGHT UP THERE WITH THE NEED
FOR EQUIPMENT AND GOOD STAR
BECAUSE WITHOUT TO IT'S NOT
THE WOULD MATTER FACT RIGHT I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT HOUSING IN
PARTICULAR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
I KNOW THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
IS HAVING A HARD TIME FINDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT WHEN
YOU ADD IN A DISABILITY AND THE
NEED FOR ACCESSIBILITY IT IS
THE WORST THE ABSOLUTE WORST
A FEW YEARS BACK I WAS GIVEN
A NOTICE THAT TIME I WOULD
HAVE TO MOVE OUT OF THE AND
PUT ONE TIME I HAD LIVED IN
FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS NOT
BECAUSE I WAS A BATTER INTO I
DIDN'T THROW ANY WILD PARTIES
I DIDN'T MAKE A LOT OF NOISE
I DIDN'T EVEN BREAK AND THE
THINGS THAT WAS SINCE MINE
WHICH IS IMPRESSIVE SINCE I
LIVED THERE THROUGH THE BUDGET
CUTS OF THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
THE ONLY THING I HAD TO DANCE
TO ME IS THAT I RELY ON SECTION
EIGHT TO HELP PAY MY RENT THE
COMPLEX I LIVED AND GAVE ME A
LOT OF TIME TO FIND A NEW PLACE
AND I SEARCHED VERY HARD TO
FIND A PLACE THAT WOULD MEET
MY NEEDS IN BEING BOTH AFFABLE
AND ARE SENSIBLE ABOUT THREE
YEARS LATER RETURNS DOWN TO
THE WIRE AND I STILL DIDN'T
HAVE A PLACE IT WAS MAKING ME
SICK TO MY STOMACH EVERY DAY
WITH AN EVICTION LOOMING ON
I WAS FINALLY ABLE TO FIND A
PLACE BUT LIKE SO MANY I HAD
TO SACRIFICE A LOT TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER MY HEAD AND HAD TO
MOVE INTO A REALLY BAD PART TO
VAN TEAL'C THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN THREE ATTEMPTS TO BREAK
INCHES SITE EVEN HAD TO GET
AN ALARM THAT COMES OUT OF A
BUDGET TOOL READY STRETCHED
TOO THIN IN ADDITION TO BEING
IN AN UNSAFE AREAS THAT ARE
UTILIZED ANTENNAE PLACE TO
SHOP FOR GROCERIES WITHIN
THE SAFE FOR LAYING DISTANCE
AND VETERAN TENNEY BUS STOPS
OUR CANOES SO I HAVE TO USE
PARA TRANSIT ANOTHER ROUTE
TO POCKET COST THIS NOT ONLY
LIMITS MIND DEPENDENT SENDING
COM IT CRAMPS MY STYLE AT
MY OLD APARTMENT TIME I WAS
ABLE TO RIDE THE BUS OR VISIT
LOCAL SHOPS ONE ON NEEDED
I JUST WANT TO BE THE PERSON
I WAS MEANT TO BE TO LIVE
THE LIFE I SHOULD BE ABLE TO
LIVE NOTHING CRAZY NOTHING
FANCY JUST DECENT PLACE
DATA I CAN CALL MY OWN AS I
TRY TO MAKE IT THROUGH THIS
LIFE PLEASE HELP US PLEASE
HELP OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
NICOLE WILL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
NICKEL FROM OUR PANEL NOW IT
NOT INITIALLY QUESTION BUT
YOU MENTION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I THINK THAT'S SO AWESOME
TO BRING OUT BECAUSE WE WE
ACTUALLY QUITE OFTEN OVERLOOKED
THAT AND SO IN ITS SUCH A HUGE
HUGE PART OF IT SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT UP IN AND --
WE JUST MET BUT I THINK YOU'RE
INCREDIBLE I THINK YOU'RE
AWESOME AND SO HAPPY TO HAVE
MET YOU AND LOOK FOR TO SEE YOU
IN SACRAMENTO BUT YOU'RE GREAT
SPOKESWOMAN FOR THE COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
NO QUESTION JUST WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT -- I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLY AWESOME
AND -- IT'S MY HONOR AND I'M
HUMBLED TO BE IN YOUR PRESENCE
TONIGHT -- I LOOK FOR TO US
WORKING TOGETHER COLLABORATING
AND NORMALLY I WOULD TELL
SOMEONE OF YOUR STATURE THAT
YOU WALK ON WATER BUT IN
YOUR CASE YOU ROLL ON WATER
COOL UNITED HAD A RELATIONSHIP
FOR A LOT OF YEARS BACK IN THE
DAY WHEN I WAS JUST A CANDIDATE
AND -- YOU'VE INSPIRED ME
TO CONTINUE THIS THIS ROLE
AND I GOTTA TELL YOU THAT'S
THE SEXIEST ACCENT I'VE EVER
THANK YOU AND KEEP BRING IT
WILL'S
THE GOOD NEWS IS JUST GOING
TO GET A NEW DEVICE IT DOESN'T
WASTE SEVEN HUNDRED POUNDS
YOU MEAN I DON'T HAVE TO THE
GYM TOMORROW I'M GOOD -- SHOVE
AN IPAD BUT SHE SHE LOSES THE
ACCENTS WHICH WILL NO LONGER
HAVE THAT BEAUTIFUL ENGLISH
ACCENT YOU KNOW THE ONE WITH
THE BEAUTIFUL BRITISH ACCENT
ON A COLEY OKAY NINE O'CLOCK
SAID IT'S ACTUALLY THE MOST
UNDERSTANDABLE BOX BUT THERE'S
BOXES WITH MEDI CAL BY NOT
BUYING AYE BECAUSE NIGHT PAT
SHE COULD SHE COULD SURF THE
INTERNET YOU KNOW AND DO THINGS
THAT NOT JUST COMMUNICATION SO
THEY'LL BUY AN EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLAR BOX BUT NOT A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR BOX THERE'S
A PLACE TO GET SOME SAVINGS
WE MAY LOSE THE ACCENT BUT WE
STILL HAVE THE BEAUTIFUL SMILE
THANK YOU NICOLE THANK YOU
NOW WE HAVE TO MOVE MY
STOCKING CREW THAT STOCK ME
AT THE CAPITOL WE HAVE AUDRA
THE FREEDOM
IT'S REALLY MY JOB OF THAT
HI I'M I'M UNDER THEM AND
THERE BEGIN THE DIGITAL CAMERA
AIM AND LABOR ROOM MAY IRWIN
ALLEN KNEW WOMEN HOWEVER DID
TO THEM EVERY MORNING AND THE
COMMUNITY AND I AM THANKS WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS COWORKERS
HOMEOWNERS WHO WERE THERE IS
TWO FOUR EIGHT AM WORRIED THEY
READ WE ARE VERY OWN THEIR BILL
IS ONLY AS THEIR ONLY BE DO
YOU DO NUMBER ALL ROBERT TERM
AND ONE RELAY WON'T WORK IT
IS VERY ONE ZERO ALL GIVE THEM
OR DRIVERS OR BANDS THERE WERE
IS THERE A AND DURING HUNDRED
IN THAT I HAVE TO DO WE ME AND
MEMBERS WE GIVE ME ME MEMBER IN
IMPROPERLY AMBER BREEZE AND
I HAVE TO DO THAT -- DO YOU
ANOTHER VIEW -- WHERE'S NOR
WILL BALL RUMORED TO HAVE WE
SHOWED THEM AND THE DRIVERS --
MEMBER FOR AS A RULE WITH THEIR
ATTITUDE TOWARDS YOUR REYES
HEY RENEE DIZZY MORE
FROM THE DRIVER TOWARD THE
ROTORS EVERYBODY Z.
EVERYWHERE THE DRIVERS TO BE
MORE AWARE OF WHERE THEY DROVE
THEIR RIDERS AND THAT THERE ARE
NO IN THIS SAVE HIM REMEMBER
THEY THEY YOU I -- THROUGH
AND MORE IN TRAINING AND
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE USUALLY
GEARS HERE DO YOU HEY
WERE AND ALWAYS DO -- JEWS
IN A BED BIGELOW
BOTH DRIVER THING YOU
ANY QUESTIONS WATER
FROM THE PANEL
JUST ON -- BY THE WAY I
LOVE YOUR ACCENT AS WELL
AND -- ON THE ON THE
TRANSPORTATION PART I WAS
WINNING AS MUCH AS I COULD OUT
OF IT -- I GUESS MY QUESTION
WOULD EITHER BE FOR YOU OR
FOR THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ON THE TRANSPORTATION SIDE
OF IT ARE IS THERE SPECIAL
FUNDING THAT COMES SPECIFIC
TO TRANSPORTATION AND IS THAT
MONEY SO RESTRICTED THAT CAN
ONLY BE USED IN ONE WAY OR
CAN IT BE USED AND MULTIPLE
-- VENUES OF OF TRANSPORTATION
THERE IS THERE'S LIMITATIONS
IN TERMS OF MEDIAN RATES FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HOWEVER
I THINK AUDREY YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT PARA TRANSIT WHICH IS
ACTUALLY PARA TRANSIT FUNDING
THAT MANY MANY PEOPLE SERVE BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER ACCESS AND
SO PARA TRANSIT HAS LIMITED
VANS AND THERE AREN'T AS MANY
ACCESSIBLE RIGHTS ON THINGS
LIKE LIFTER -- BIRTH THAT
PEOPLE CAN USE AS WELL YEAH
THANK YOU SO ADDRESS SO --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
AND I HAVE WORKED ON IS --
YOUR PHYSICAL WELLBEING AND
YOU'RE GOING OUT RACING NOW
AND SO CAN YOU TELL THE THE
PANEL BUT HOW LONG YOU STAY
ON THE TREADMILL OKAY THEIR
OWN -- MY AND THEN THE MINUTE
ON NO HELLO AGAIN STAN I'M IS
TOO BIG ONE THERE DID FIFTY
MINUTES TO THIRTY MINUTES
FOR THE INDEPENDENT CHANNEL
MAYBE WILL LET ME USE THEM FOR
A LONG MAY DO MORE OVER ONE
DAY
ONE NOTE FOR THE PANEL TO
NOTICE IT AUTHOR DOES RIDE
THE BUS -- OFF WITH OTHER
FOLKS WHO ARE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
BOTH SPEECH AND OUR LANGUAGE
COMMUNICATION CHALLENGES
AND ONE DAY ONE OF OUR FOLKS
CAME INTO WARMER PROGRAMS AND
DIDN'T LOOK RIGHTS FOR LOOK
DISABLED DAUGHTER GOT OFF DROVE
UP TO THAT SIDE WATCHES IT
DID YOU KNOW THAT SHE WASN'T
STRAPPED DOWN THE TIPPED OVER
ON THE BUS SO WE HAD TO FOLLOW
SPECIALISTS REPORT DO THAT
THE BUS DRIVER HAD DONE BUT
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE SHE SAID HEY THAT'S NOT
OKAY SO OUR FOLKS LOOK OUT FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR OTHERS AND
REPORT THAT SO YOU KNOW SHE'S
A ROCKS ARE A LOT OF WAYS SO
WILL BE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
TO ADD ABOUT EMPLOYMENT --
SINCE FEATURES EXPLORED AND WE
GOT A FEW FEW MINUTES WOULD IF
YOU WOULD JUST FOR THE PANEL
AND SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE -- YEAH THE ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT A GREAT ECONOMY
IS THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS THE
BAD THING ABOUT AGREED UPON
ACADEMY IS WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFF TO SUPPORT OUR GUYS TO
GET EMPLOYMENT -- SO BLOOM IS
BEEN UNDER FUNDED FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS AND WE HAVE DONE
SOMETHING LEGISLATORS SECOND
SOME ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FULLY ACCESS --
SUMMERS COMES WITH THE RULES
ALONG THE WAY SO WE EMPLOY
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOLKS
TO WORK ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES
-- IT OF WRITINGS FROM WORKING
FULL TIME IN THE COMMUNITY
TO WORK IN A COUPLE HOURS FOR
FOLKS ARE PRETTY LIMITED ATER
ACTUALLY WORKS ARTHUR STORE FOR
US -- THE CALL WORKS IS IN THE
TRAINER ADVOCATE AND MENTOR SHE
ACTUALLY -- LEAVE ADVOCATE ON A
BILL THAT WAS PASSED -- TO PUT
CHANGING TABLES ADULT CHANGE
TABLES AND PUBLIC FACILITIES
-- TO DO THAT SO EMPLOYMENT
SOME THERE IS A DRIVER RIGHT
NOW IS IN THE SYSTEM AND WERE
PRETTY WANTS YOU'LL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WHERE EMPLOYMENT
FOR STATE -- WE HAVE A SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WE SPEND
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION ON OF
THAT SUPPORTING COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATE IMPLEMENT SO WE
HAVEN'T PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS RELATED TO THAT AND
SO THEY REALLY NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO IMPROVE AND AND
INCREASE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FOLKS IS GET OUR GUYS ARE
GREAT EMPLOYEES TO DO GREAT JOB
THEY JUST WANT THE OPPORTUNITY
AND ARE CHALLENGES THAT WE
NEED TO BUILD A TO HAVE FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM --
WITH THE PANEL IT IN SACRAMENTO
MY EMPLOYMENT SPECIALISTS ARE
DIRECTOR SAID YOU KNOW I'VE WAY
THIS TO FORTY FOLKS WHO WANT
A JOB I DON'T HAVE THE STAFF
GET NOTHING DO THAT SO THAT'S
REALLY ARE PROBABLY BIGGEST
CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW THROUGH
THE DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONAL
GETTING PEOPLE TO BE ABLE WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY SO I GUESS
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS TO THE
BEAN COUNTERS IN SACRAMENTO
IS THAT IF WE CREATE SUCCESSES
IN THROUGH YOUR EMPLOYMENT WE
TAKE PEOPLE OFF OF ASSISTANCE
REDUCE ASSISTANCE ALLOWS THEM
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE IN DIFFERENT HOUSING THAT
THEY DO CURRENTLY THE OTHER
THING WITH HOUSING IS NOT ONLY
DO OUR FOLKS I'VE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT THEM INFORMAL HOUSING
ALSO AND SO ONE OF THINGS ARE
REALLY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
TRY TO DO IS LOOK AT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACROSS MULTIPLE THINGS
DON'T BILL DISABILITY SPECIFIC
HOUSING BILLS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE COMMUNITY CAN LIVE
IN AND OUR GUYS ARE JUST PART
OF THAT MIX SO YEAH ABSOLUTELY
MORE WE CAN THE MOVE PEOPLE
FOR THE MORE THEY BECOME
CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
DOES REDUCE SSI OTHER COSTS
ALSO PEOPLE WHO WORK OFFICER
TO PICK UP HEALTH BENEFITS AND
ARE WITH THE OTHER VERY THIS
HEART USUALLY JUST NOT REALLY
FROM THE CITY CALIFORNIA IS
THE SSI RULES MEDICARE MEDICARE
AL ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE I CAN'T
WORK BECAUSE I'M A LOSE MY SSI
AS IF THAT'S THE GOLDEN TICKET
AND REALITY THAT JUST MEANS
YOU'RE LIVING IN POVERTY RATE
YOU GET A JOB YOU DO MUCH MORE
IF THERE'S A WAY FOR THAT TO
REALLY AFFECTED SO ABSOLUTE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL WILL
SO I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
THE -- THE HONORABLE KANSEN
CHU ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN JOSE IS COME TODAY TO
JOIN US THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'D LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING
I'M SORRY LAID YOU KNOW THE
TRAFFIC WAS TERRIBLE -- -- --
-- FIVE EIGHT FIVE FIVE EIGHT
HE A SIXTY AND I CAME FROM
THE SAN JOSE AREA BUT -- I'M
HAPPY TO I I THOUGHT I MADE IT
IN A I WANT TO TAKE THAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAYING CUT --
MISTER FREEZER FOR ORGANIZING
THIS LISTENING SESSION YOU
KNOWN MISTER FRASER IS A VERY
POWERFUL OWED -- A MEMBERS SAY
IN THE ASSEMBLY IS THE CHAIR OF
THE -- TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
AND -- WORKING VERY VERY HARD
TO THE TO SOLVE THE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION THE ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE UP ON SIX SIX EIGHTY SO
THE BUT HE'S ALSO A VERY VERY
-- A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR OF
PEOPLE WAS -- -- THE DISABILITY
I KNOW -- EARLIER THIS YEAR
HE EVEN HAVE ONE OF THE IS
-- OF PEOPLE WITH THE OF THE
DISABILITY YOU ARE OF OF PEOPLE
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS -- WORKING
IN HIS -- CAPITOL OFFICE SO
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH --
AND IS REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE
AYE A OF A PART OF THE -- A
SAN ANDREAS BIG REGIONAL CENTER
AND -- I WAS -- IN DEER YEAH --
YOU BAND LAST WEEKEND AND -- I
GOT A CHANCE TO GET UP ON THE
STAGE IN AFTER LISTENING TO THE
A DREAM ACHIEVER BAND -- I A
-- GOT A MOTHER THEIR DATA TRY
AND I I JUST MADE A COMMENT TO
SAY TO MAKE NEXT YEAR WHEN THEY
GO BACK TO SACRAMENTO I'D LIKE
TO CHANGE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF A DISABILITY TO WHAT
THROUGH A DISABILITY THAT THAT
NO YEAH OUT TO PALM OF OF A
DIFFERENT ABILITY SO DID DOES
THE BECAUSE OF MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE WAS A SPECIAL NEED A
HOUSE OR A LOT OF HIDDEN TALENT
AND -- -- NOT ONLY THEY CAN --
BY PERFORM A YOU KNOW IF THE
PLAYER TO PLAY IN THE BAND AND
THEIR THEIR ART EXHIBIT THAT
EVENING WAS WONDERFUL AS WELL
SO AGAIN -- POLY JOYS BEING
LATE BUT AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREEZER
FOR ORGANIZING THIS LISTENING
SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING SICK
CITY CLEARED OUT FOR YOU TODAY
WORKING ON IT TO WORK IN
PROGRESS I THINK I'D BE BETTER
OFF JUST FLYING YEAR BUT
ANYWAY -- THANK YOU TO OUR
OUR PANELISTS TODAY WHAT WE
CAN DO IS MOVE ON TO A PUBLIC
COMMENTS IT'LL HAVE TO REMIND
YOU WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU TWO
TO THREE MINUTES BECAUSE WE
PROBABLY HAVE A TON OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES TO THIS PANEL SO
WHAT I'M ASKING IS THOSE WHO
CAN STAND IN LINE OF AND COME
TO THE PODIUM AND -- PLEASE
DON'T BE OFFENDED IF WE DO SHUT
YOU OFF AFTER THREE MINUTES
PLEASE WILL YOU PLEASE YEAH
OKAY
HE'S GOT A TIME
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA DO START
OFF WITH YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU LIVE OKAY MY NAME IS ORANGE
PERSON I'M A CONSUMER SOME
OWNERS -- I AM IN DISABLED
ARTIST AND VERY VERY MAD
ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS AND BY
HELPING IN THE STATE I FOUND
OUT THAT WE CANNOT GET FOOD
STAMPS AND OUR STATE WITH OUR
SECURITY -- IN I THINK THAT'S
WRONG BECAUSE IF YOU GO IN
THE STATE OF NEVADA YOU CAN
GET SO -- CARESSES I AND YOU
CAN GET FOOD STAMPS AND MOST
OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR PROGRAM
THE ADAPTIVE LEARNING CENTER
ONLY GET SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH AND THAT'S ONE THING
THAT MAKES ME EXTREMELY MAD
AND I THINK THE LAW SHOULD BE
CHANGED SECONDLY A LOT OF THE
COUNTIES HAVE A CLOSER SECTION
EIGHT LIST AND THEY CAN'T GET
ON SECTION EIGHT AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THAT THE
SECTION EIGHT IN -- WITH THIS
COUNTING AND A LOT OF OTHER
COUNTIES ARE CLOSED AND WE
CANNOT AFFORD THE HEIGHT RENTS
IN THE APARTMENT AND SECOND
SECONDLY I HAVE HIGH
FUNCTIONING AUTISM THE ONLY
PROGRAM I'VE BEEN IN FOR TWENTY
ONE YEARS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
I EITHER HAVE THAT PROGRAM OR
A HAVE DISTRICT SO WE NEED MORE
PROGRAMS WITH AUTISM FOR HIGH
RANKING PEOPLE WITH AUTISM AND
IT MAKES ME REALLY MAD WHEN I
FIND OUT PEOPLE OF LEFT TO OUR
PROGRAM AND IF INDEED OUT ON
THE STREET BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE
BAD CHOICES AND THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE IN IT MAKES ME REALLY MAD
AND STUFF AND SO I HAD TO SPEAK
MY LITTLE MAN ABOUT IT AND
THERE'S SOME OTHER THINGS ALSO
THE PROGRAM I'M IN IF I DIDN'T
HAVE MY ART THERAPY AM A GARDEN
THIRTY I WOULD PROBABLY BE
CLIMBING THE WALLS INSIDE THE
PROGRAM AND I NEED THAT TO KEEP
MYSELF AND ST BASICALLY AND SO
WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS BASICALLY
WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES WITH
HOUSING AND ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE WITH HIGH FUNCTIONING
AUTISM AND SO I WOULD GET WE
NEED THOSE AND BASICALLY THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED IT SPECIALLY N.
AROUND THE STATE AND SO IF
WE CAN DO THIS WE NEED TO GET
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT -- ALSO
WHEN I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH MY
DISABILITY BACK IN THE DAY
BECAUSE I'M FORTY THREE YEARS
OLD THEY GIVE ME THE DIAGNOSIS
I WAS MAINLY A BORDERLINE
MILLER RETIRED WELL I PROVED
THAT SOMETIMES I'M NOT FINALLY
I FOUND WHEN I WAS ALMOST
FORTY THAT I ACTUALLY HAD
I'VE HIGH FUNCTIONING AUTISM
I WAS ALMOST FORTY UNTIL THEY
GAVE ME THE RIGHT LABEL AND
SO WE'RE GONNA START HAVING
INFLUXES WITH PEOPLE THAT NEED
AUTISM SERVICES BASICALLY I
WANTED THEY SUPPOSED TO DO
THERE'S NO SERVICES SO WE
BASICALLY THE STATE NEEDS
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THE END THANK YOU THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU LIVE I'M DOUGLAS QUIN
I HAVE MORE PROBLEMS THAN
DISABILITIES I HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEM LIFE FEELINGS I HAVE
-- EMOTIONS PEOPLE DON'T SEEM
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN A BABY
IS BORN IN THIS WORLD WITH A
BIRTH DEFECT THEY'LL ALWAYS
HAVE THAT BIRTH DEFECT THEY
WILL NEVER GET BETTER DOES NO
SUCH THING AS A P.
ILL THEY GET THROUGH THE
DISABILITIES NOBODY GETS THAT
IT DOESN'T JUST TAKE MONEY
AND PUTTING BUILDING IS UP AND
PEOPLE BEDROOMS AND SPECIAL
OF IT TAKES UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WE GO THROUGH ALL OUR LIVES
TODAY I HAD A PROBLEM I'M SO
I HATE BEING DISABLED I HATE
IT NOBODY UNDERSTANDS HOW
THAT FEELS SOME B.
BALL CAN'T WALK SOME PEOPLE
CAN'T TALK AND THEY'RE SAYING
PLENTY NOW LISTEN THERE IS
NO SUCH THING IN THE WORLD
TODAY EVER GIVE ME MONEY FOR
EVERYBODY YOU GOT TO START
UNDERSTANDING TO US SOME
PEOPLE WHO NEED THE MONEY
MORE THAN OTHER PEOPLE THANK
YOU WELL SIR CORRECT SIR
PLEASE PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME
AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM PLEASE
MY NAME IS ALEX WHITMAN I
LIVE IN A GROUP HOME CAN'T
CONTENT AND CAME HERE DO OUR
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT YOU
CAN THAT YOU CAN THE OF A AS A
COMMENT ON THE CASE FOR A MUCH
THE FOURTH POINT I'D LIKE TO
DIRECT THE WITH A THEIR FIVE BY
HOUSE IN AN NAY X.
FOR MORE FUNDING SEC BEND AND
PUT THE SECOND POINT S.
TRANSPORTATION RENAME
OF FUNNY VÀ SAYS A BONE
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CAN TEST
PLEASE LEAVE YOUR NAME AND
WHERE YOU'RE FROM MY NAME IS
DEBORAH DARDEN I LIVE IN CASTRO
VALLEY I HAVE A SON WHO'S FORTY
ONE YEARS OLD WHO'S ON THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM AND WE HAVE
ALL THE SAME PROBLEMS AS THESE
YOUNG MEN HAVE TALKED ABOUT
AND THIS YOUNG WOMAN BUT MY
BIGGEST CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS MY
SON WENT THROUGH AN EXPERIENCE
WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THAT LANDED HIM IN
PRISON FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS
THE DA SAID TO US MULTIPLE
TIMES I DON'T CARE THAT HE
HAS DISABILITY HE WAS ALLOWED
TO BE INTERROGATED AND SELF
INCRIMINATE HIMSELF HE WAS
CHARGED WITH THE MOST EGREGIOUS
CHARGES THAT THEY COULD COME
UP WITH THEY WANTED TO SENTENCE
HIM TO PRISON FOR THIRTY YEARS
THEY WANT TO STRIKE HIM OUT
HIS FIRST TIME BEING ARRESTED
THERE IF THE COMMUNITY IS WHERE
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE COMMUNITY HAS GOT
TO ACCEPT THEM THEY HAVE TO BE
SAFE THERE THE LARGEST GROWING
POPULATION IN PRISON SYSTEM
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES MY SEND IN BELONG
THERE HE DIDN'T DESERVE WHAT
HE GOT THERE NEEDS TO BE
LEGISLATION ABOUT INTERROGATING
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE MENTAL
CAPACITY OF A TEN YEAR OLD
THERE NEEDS TO BE LEGISLATION
THAT SAYS YOU CANNOT YOU
CAN ALLOW THIS PERSON SELF
INCRIMINATE HIMSELF THAT YOU
CANNOT LOCK HIM IN AN ADULT
FACILITY AND EXPECT HIM TO FEND
FOR HIMSELF IN A PLACE LIKE
CORCORAN OR SAN QUENTIN WHICH
ARE THE TWO PLACES THAT HE WENT
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
I CAN DO TO HELP BRING
THAT ABOUT ON HIS BEHALF
FAMILIES YOUR NAME AND
NUMBER WILL WILL BE
WORKING TOGETHER THANK
WHERE YOU FROM I'M CHANCE
DIRECTLY I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HOUSING CHOICES WHERE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
SAN ANDREAS REGIONAL CENTER TO
CREATE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
HOUSING NEEDS THE HOUSING
CRISIS AS IT'S AFFECTING OUR
COMMUNITY AND ALSO PUT OUT SOME
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE I'VE HEARD
YOU SEVERAL TIMES ASKED FOR
SOLUTIONS -- ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BUT PARTICULARLY IN THE BAY
AREA WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY
THAT I KNOW PASSED BETWEEN
SIXTY PERCENT AND SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE LIVING IN THE HOME OF
AGING PARENTS IF YOU TALK
TO ANY OF THOSE PARENTS BUT
THEY'LL TELL YOU IS I HAVE AN
EXPIRATION DATE I'M WORRIED
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN I'M NO LONGER ABLE
TO BE THE HOUSING PROVIDER AND
THE PRIMARY SERVICE PROVIDER
FOR MY ADULT SO HOUSING IS
A HUGE NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND -- THEY NEED IS GROWING
-- THE NUMBER OF ADULTS IN THE
THIRTY TO FORTY YEAR OLD RANGE
IS ABOUT TO DOUBLE AND THAT
INCREASE IS GOING TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE OF AN INCREASE IN THE
AUTISM DIAGNOSIS THAT BEGAN
ABOUT THIRTY YEARS AGO THE
OTHER FACTOR IS ARE ADULTS
ARE LIVING LONGER THANKS HER
SERVICE SYSTEM -- SO WE NOW
SEE MOST PEOPLE LIVING INTO
THEIR SIXTIES AND BEYOND
WHEN BEFORE THERE WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF IN THE
EARLY FIFTIES ON THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS SOMETHING THAT A
FAX CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
AND PEOPLE OF MANY DIFFERENT
INCOME LEVELS BUT IT TAKES
THE GREATEST TOLL ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- WE WORK WITH
SENATE RACE WE DON'T CENTER
TO HELP PEOPLE APPLY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THERE'S A
HUGE SHORTAGE AND WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS WE NEED TO CREATE
SPECIFIC HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
WITH STATE HOUSING FINANCE
SOURCES TARGETED TO PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
BECAUSE WE NEED TO CONNECT
THE HOUSING OPPORTUNITY WITH
THIS WONDERFUL SUPPORT SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE TO OUR REGIONAL
SENT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
ALL OF OUR STATE FINANCED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIRES
THAT AT LEAST TEN PERCENT
OF THE UNITS BE ACCESSIBLE
TO PEOPLE WHO NEED PHYSICAL
ACCESSIBILITY I WOULD POINT OUT
TO YOU THAT PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
AND COGNITIVE DISABILITIES
HAVE THE SINGLE HIGHEST RATE
OF HOUSING DISCRIMINATION OF
ANY OTHER DISABLED GROUP SO WE
HAVE THIS TARGET FOR CREATING
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE
WITH PHYSICAL DISABILITIES
WE SHOULDN'T CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE STATE HOUSING FINANCE
SOURCES WITHOUT A TARGET FOR
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
YOU BASS ABOUT FUNDING SOURCES
THAT'S A FINANCING SYSTEM THAT
ALREADY EXCESS WHAT YOU NEED
TO GO IN IS AND RETOOL THAT
FINANCING SYSTEM SO THAT PEOPLE
WITH INTENSE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ARE INTENTIONALLY INCLUDE
IF YOU DON'T INTENTIONALLY
INCLUDE US WITH THE SUPPORT
OF SERVICE SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER WE WILL BE
LEFT OUT AND HIS PARENTS AGE
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A GROWING
PHENOMENON OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONG SEVERELY DISABLED ADULTS
-- SO LOOK AT SPECIALIZED
FINANCING SOURCES EVERY OTHER
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION HAS
A TARGETED HOUSING FINANCE
IMAGE CRAP OKAY SO LOOK AT
BOTH OF THOSE PLEASE THANK YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM ABIGAIL OCCURRED
I I'M WITH EASTER SEALS BAY
AREA AND WALNUT CREEK AND
I'M TAYLOR ASHFORD FOR YOUR
REPRESENTING THE KALEIDOSCOPE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU OUR HERE
COMMUNITY ADULTS PROGRAM
WHICH IS -- HELD THROUGH
EASTER SEALS BAY AREA PROVIDES
VOLUNTEER OPPORTUNITIES
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS LIFE SOCIAL AND
INDEPENDENCE SKILLS -- FOR
ADULTS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
SPECIAL NEEDS -- OUR BIGGEST
HURDLE IS TRANSPORTATION
UNFORTUNATELY -- THE TRANSIT
PROVIDERS WHO ARE WILLING
TO PROVIDE TRANSIT FOR OUR
CLIENTS -- ARE UNFORTUNATELY
NOT FUNDED THROUGH REGIONAL
CENTER OF EAST BAY -- COUNTY
CONNECTION EAST BAY TRANSIT
-- THEY HOLD INTERVIEWS THAT
HAVE VERY SOLIDLY RESULTED
IN DISQUALIFICATION FOR ALL
OF OUR PARTICIPANTS TO DATE
-- ONE EXAMPLE -- WE HAVE
ONE CLIENT WHO IS NEW TO THE
AREA HIS FAMILY'S HOME WAS
DESTROYED IN HURRICANE HARVEY
THEY LIVE HERE NOW HE DOES NOT
KNOW THE AREA SO HE HAS QUOTE
UNQUOTE FAILED HIS INTERVIEWS
WITH SOME OF THESE TRANSIT
PROVIDERS -- TO OTHERS GET
VERY NERVOUS AROUND FIGURES OF
AUTHORITY AND GIVE THE ANSWERS
THEY THINK WILL APPEASE THEIR
INTERVIEWERS EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE INCORRECT AND THAT RESULTS
IN THEIR DISQUALIFICATION --
WE ALSO HAVE -- PARENTS WHO
ARE PAYING UBER OUT OF THEIR
POCKET TO SEND THEIR THEIR
CHILDREN TO OUR PROGRAM WE
ALSO HAVE PARENTS WHO CARPOOL
IT RESULTS IN THEM BEING LATE
TO WORK AND THEY'RE BEING
REPRIMANDED OUT WORK IF THEY
LOSE THEIR JOBS THEIR CHILDREN
NO LONGER QUALIFY FOR SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY'RE AT HOME NOW
WE HAVE FIVE CLIENTS HERE
IN CONCORD WHO ARE READY AND
WAITING TO JOIN OUR PROGRAM
HOWEVER THEY CAN'T JOIN
WITHOUT TRANSPORTATION SO --
WE DESPERATELY NEED BETTER
EDUCATION FOR SOME OF THESE
TRANSIT PROVIDERS FOR THEIR
INTERVIEW PROCESS SO IT'S MORE
SUS SYNC MORE TAILORED TO OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND WE ALSO NEED
-- MORE OPTIONS AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS MORE FUNDING SO WE
CAN HAVE THOSE WILLING TRANSIT
PROVIDERS ACT LEE TAKE OUR
PARTICIPANTS SOMEWHERE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT THEY'RE GONNA
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES AND I CAN
BE ABLE TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
THANKS THANK YOU SO MUCH
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WERE
YOU FROM NANCY EDDIE I'M FROM
FREMONT I'M THE MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN WITHIN REGIONAL
CENTER THE EAST BAY AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF DEAF PLUS
ADULT COMMUNITY A DAY PROGRAM
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAF WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS -- YOU KNOW
ALL THE SAME ISSUES HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION EVERYTHING
AFFECTS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEAF BUT IT'S AMPLIFIED BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE COMMUNICATION
-- WE'RE THE ONLY PROGRAM
IN THE BAY AREA THAT WILL
ACCEPT SOMEBODY WITH BEHAVIOR
CHALLENGES AND PROVIDE
COMMUNICATION THAT'S REALLY
A SHAME -- I'VE HAD PEOPLE
COME TO FREMONT FROM AS FAR AS
YOUR IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM WE NEED MORE
-- AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT ALL
OF THESE ISSUES I'D ASK THAT
YOU THINK IN TERMS OF ALSO
PROVIDING COMMUNICATION FOR
THOSE WHO ARE DEAF -- YOU KNOW
IT'S A STRUGGLE MY STAFF FOR
ALL DOUBTS AS WELL -- IT'S
BEEN A LONG TIME COMING BUT NOW
REGIONAL CENTER WILL PROVIDE
INTERPRETERS FOR THE CLASSES
WE HAVE TO GO TO -- THAT'S NOT
TRUE IN OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS
NECESSARILY SO I THINK JUST ONE
MORE PIECE TO THE PUZZLE IS THE
DEAFNESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER
WE HAVE HAVE AN HONORABLE X.
FISHY -- THAT WAS -- VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE LEGISLATURE
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE THANK
THANK YOU FOR MEMBER AND AND --
PROUD TO BE HERE AND THANKFUL
THAT YOU'RE ALL HERE AND
AND -- FOR HAVING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND EVERYBODY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS SO
-- I WANT TO ECHO WHAT A LOT
OF AT LEAST A SAID SHE KIND
OF GAVE A LOT OF THE BULLET
POINTS AS TO WHAT THE KIND OF
THE LOW HANGING FRUIT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
YOU KNOW THAT THE HALF DAY THE
HOLIDAYS -- THE THE THE MEDIAN
RATES IF YOU COULD GIVE US A
LOT MORE MONEY BUT IF YOU DON'T
CHANGE THE MEANING RATES WE
CAN'T SPEND IT -- SO REALLY
IS KIND OF A A BIG BIG PROBLEM
-- IN TRYING TO GET MORE MONEY
TO US -- ALSO THOSE OF ABOUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE MONEY WILL IT'S REALLY
MAKING IT A PRIORITY BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN NO NET INCREASE IN
SIXTEEN YEARS -- I KNOW WE HAD
AN INCREASE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THOUSAND BACK FILL FROM CUTS
THAT WE HAD DURING MY TIME IN
THE LEGISLATURE -- SO -- ALL
THE OTHER COMPONENTS IN THE
STATE BUDGET YOUR EDUCATION
A LAW ENFORCEMENT EXCEPT ARE
THEY IF THEY DON'T HAVE AN
INCREASE EVERY YEAR IT'S IT'S
A CRISIS -- WE GO SIXTEEN
YEARS -- WITHOUT A NET INCREASE
IT'S A IT'S A CATASTROPHE
-- TRANSPORTATION ECHO THAT
-- MY -- MY COMPANY IS A
MISSION HOPE DAY PROGRAM WE
SIR FOREIGN FIFTY A BEHAVIORAL
CLIENTS -- EVERY DAY WE HAVE
A TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM --
IS SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED BUT
TRANSPORTATION FOR EVERYBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL -- YOU KNOW AND YOU
IN THE IN A GREAT POSITION TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THAT -- IF YOU ALL THE IDEAS
FOR SELF DETERMINATION --
PERSON CENTERED OF PLANNING
AND AND PROGRAMS IF YOU CAN'T
GET THERE THEN IT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT -- YOU ASK A OF
CUSTOM INSIDE BASEBALL STUFF
IS TO WILL HOW CAN MAKE THINGS
BETTER ONE THING IS THAT WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS KIND
OF THE RATES WITHIN THE RATES
SO IF YOU -- IF YOU FIND --
-- THE DOLLARS TO GIVE TO THE
COMMUNITY IF YOU JUST DO THE
STANDARD THING OF WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE EVERYBODY A FIVE
PERCENT INCREASE ACROSS THE
BOARD -- THAT ISN'T REALLY
TAKE SOME OF THE STRUCTURAL
ISSUES OUT OF IT FOR INSTANCE
AT MISSION HOPE IN OUR WE HAVE
SIX DIFFERENT LOCATIONS AND
OUR RATES FOR TRANSPORTATION
FOURTEEN DOLLARS AND FORTY SIX
NINETEEN THIRTY TWELVE DOLLARS
AND THIRTY EIGHT CENTS TWELVE
HOURS AND THIRTY EIGHT CENTS
AND SO IF YOU GIVE EVERYBODY
AN INCREASE THEN A FIVE PERCENT
INCREASE THAN THOSE ONES THAT
ARE STOCK -- JUST HAPPENSTANCE
THAT THEY STARTED THE PROGRAM
AND THEY GOT CAUGHT IN THIS IN
THIS RATE STRUCTURE -- THEY'RE
STILL WAY UNDER FUNDED AND
SO KIND OF A OF A RESET AND
HOW YOU CAN LOOK AT WHAT'S A
REALISTIC FUNDING LEVEL FOR
FOR ALL THESE PROGRAMS INSTEAD
OF JUST KIND OF RATIONING UP
WHAT HISTORICALLY HAS BUILT
UP WOULD BE -- SOMETHING TO
REALLY LOOK AT IT'S A LOT
HARDER WORK BUT IT MAKES MORE
SENSE -- AND THEN FINALLY --
WITH EVERYBODY REPRESENTED
HERE -- HAVING THESE COMMITTEE
MEETINGS -- ARE ARE FANTASTIC
BUT GET OUT THERE AND AND
VISIT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS AND
SEE PEOPLE IT STARTS GETTING
US AWAY FROM BEING NUMBERS
ON A ON A BUDGET LINE -- AND
AND PEOPLE BECAUSE EVERYBODY
HERE REPRESENTS DIFFERENT
AREAS -- IT'S ACTUALLY SENSUAL
THAT -- YOU GET OUT THERE
AND AND TO PRESS THE FLESH
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
STATE YOUR NAME WHERE YOU FROM
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AND WE
I AM FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I HAVE AN ADULT BROTHER WHO IS
-- AUTISTIC AND HAS TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY HE'S NONVERBAL
ENHANCES REPROCESSING IS ORDER
I'M HERE AS BEHALF TO ADVOCATE
-- TO MAKE SURE THAT HE IS A
VICTIM OF A CONSERVATORSHIP
ABUSIVE CONSERVATORSHIP THAT
I'M STILL FIGHTING IN COURT
TO BRING HIM HOME BACK TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS HE'S BEEN --
CHEMICALLY RESTRAINED AND AND
THE WAY THAT THEY TREATED HIM
I GAVE EVIDENCE TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS INTO THE COURTS BUT
THEY STILL GET TIED UP IN THE
COURT SYSTEM SO I'M ASKING --
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
-- BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE OF
THE STRONGEST PROBATE CODES
AND TO PROTECT FAMILY RIGHTS
AND -- CONSERVATIVE RIGHTS
BUT THERE ARE NORD AND I'M
ASKING FOR OVERSIGHT FOR THOSE
LAWS BECAUSE MY BROTHER MEAN
PHOTOS OF DUCT TAPED CLOTHING
AND WAITING BOXING GLOVES AND
COME CHRISTIANS WERE HE'S NON
RESPONSIVE AND I HAVE TO TRAVEL
FOUR HUNDRED MILES JUST TO SEE
HIM FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES AND WE
LOST OUR MOTHER LAST YEAR AND
I HAD TO GO TO COURT TO APPEAR
ON THE DAY OF HER SERVICES
TO ADVOCATE FOR BROTHER TO
PAY RESPECTS TO HIS MOM THAT
CAREFUL FOR HIM FOR OVER THIRTY
FOUR YEARS OF HIS LIFE AND WE
RELOCATED HERE TO CALIFORNIA
THINKING THAT THE RIGHTS HERE
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTERS IN
THE SYSTEM HERE TO PROTECT HIS
RIGHTS TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
TO BE PROTECTED AND SO HE CAN
CONTINUE LIVING A LIFE THAT
WE HAD BUILT FOR HIM TO BE
INDEPENDENT IN THE COMMUNITY
AND ENJOY THE LIFE AND FREEDOM
TO BE WITH FAMILY BUT WHEN WE
ARRIVED HERE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
IT WAS A NIGHTMARE AND IT WAS
TURNED OVER UPSIDE DOWN AND I'M
NOT JUST HERE FOR MY BROTHER
BUT FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO WILL
BECOME INDEPENDENT AFTER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN THERE'S GOING
TO BE URGES OF PEOPLE TO ASK
THEM TO BECOME CONSERVATORS
BUT THE CONSERVE RECESSION
DOES NOT WORK AND I'M HERE TO
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO PLEASE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY PROTECT AND
LOOK AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
NOT ABUSED SO THANK YOU SO WHAT
WE'LL DO IS HAVE A NUMBER OF
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU TO GET YOUR
INFORMATION SO WE CAN START
THE PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
POLITICAL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME ONLY
WHERE YOU LIVE I'M LINDA CAN
KID I LIVE IN SILICON VALLEY
BUT I REPRESENTING COALITION
FOR OLDER DISABILITY RIGHTS
AND WE REPRESENT PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE STATE MANY FAMILIES
TELL STORIES OF THEIR LOVED
ONES WHO ARE NEGLECTED AND
ABUSED BY REGIONAL CENTERS
AND THEIR VENDORS AS WE JUST
HEARD UNLAWFUL ISOLATION AND
CAMPBELL RESTRAINT ARE VERY
COMMON COMPLAINTS SOME FAMILIES
ALSO TELL US OF PHYSICAL ABUSE
MENTAL ABUSE SEXUAL ABUSE AND
FORCED LABOR RYAN MORRIS HAS
THE MENTAL CAPACITY OF A SIX
YEAR OLD HE'S TWENTY THREE
YEARS KUNDER CONSERVATORSHIP
AND MARRIED TO A FORTY TWO
YEAR OLD MALE ON PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE IS COMMON IN THEIR
HOME MARTIN DOING WHO YOU
JUST HEARD ABOUT HAS BEEN
ALLOWED ONLY LIMITED CONTACT
WITH HIS FAMILY FOR THE PAST
FOUR YEARS HE IS NEVER ALLOWED
PRIVATE VISITATION WITH HIS
FAMILY WHEN THEY ARE ALLOWED A
FIFTEEN MINUTE VISIT MARTIN IS
TYPICALLY PHYSICALLY SEDATED
SO THAT HE CAN NOT COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM HE HAS MANY CUTS AND
BRUISES WHEN HIS FAMILY DOES
SEE HIM WILLIAM ANTI HAS BEEN
OFF ISOLATED UNLAWFULLY FROM
HIS MOTHER SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TEN SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY
ONE WHICH WE CEDAR SPONSORED
WAS THE LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT REFUSING
TO INVESTIGATE CRIMES AGAINST
WILLIAM BILL PASSED ONE
NINETEEN TWO ZERO GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNATURE BUT WILLIAMS
STILL ISOLATED FROM HIS MOM
THERE ARE MANY MORE STORIES
LIKE THE ONES I TOLD TO MOST
FAMILIES A CONTACT US ARE
TERRIFIED OF GOING PUBLIC
THEY WON'T COMPILE COMPLAINTS
THEY WILL SHARE THEIR STORIES
PUBLICLY THEY ARE AFRAID OF
RETALIATION AGAINST THEIR LOVED
ONES WE ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
TAKE ACTION TO SEEK JUSTICE
AND SEE PROTECTION FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
HI MY NAME IS DONNA FEINGOLD
AND I LIVE IN BENICIA BUT I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ADAPTIVE LEARNING CENTER HERE
IN CONCORD SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
IN OUR LOVELY TOWN -- I'M
ALSO EXCITED BECAUSE USUALLY
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAKING NOW HAVE
THREE SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT I
WANNA SAY I'M GOING TO GO --
A SHOT -- SO I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS KIND OF WORK FOR A LONG
TIME -- LONGER THAN I'D LIKE
TO ADMIT BUT IT'S BEEN ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND FOR
ME IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE IN A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE -- WE WORK WITH SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE HOME
CITIZENS ARE OF OUR STATE AND
OUR COMMUNITIES IN IT SADDENS
ME WHEN THERE IS TALK ABOUT
WE DO IS -- HAVING TO --
GET INCREASES SO WE CAN MEET
MINIMUM WAGE -- THE THE FOLKS
WHO SUPPORT OUR STAFF WHO
SUPPORT OUR FOR FOLKS THAT WE
SERVE -- THEY ARE NOT MINIMUM
WAGE WORKERS THEY ARE SKILLED
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS WERE
COMMITTED AND PASSIONATE ABOUT
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
AND LIVING IN THE BAY AREA
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THE COST OF
LIVING IS HERE -- AND I'M SO
GLAD PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOT ONLY
FOR THE PEOPLE WE SERVE ABOUT
FOR OUR STAFF IT'S JUST --
AS THE MINIMUM WAGE KEEPS ON
GOING UP I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT COMPRESSION COMPRESSION
IS A REAL CONCERN OF OURS IN
AGENCIES ARE NOT ABLE TO HIRE
PEOPLE AND RETAIN THE STAFF
I'M REALLY GLAD OM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER YOU ASKED ABOUT
WAITING LISTS BECAUSE I'VE
GONE TO SACRAMENTO AND I'VE
HEARD DEPARTMENT SAY THERE
ARE NO WAITING LISTS BECAUSE
IT'S ONLY INTERMENT IN THIS
ENTITLEMENT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
REALITY THE REALITY IS PEOPLE
ARE GETTING SERVE NO WE'VE
HEARD IT TONIGHT BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH STAFF TO FILL
PEOPLE IN OTHER POSITIONS TO
MEET RATIOS -- WE WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND I KNOW THE QUESTION
IS WHERE IS THE MONEY THERE'S
MONEY WITH THE CLOSURE OF THE
THE STATE HOSPITALS THERE'S
MONEY THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
IN OUR SYSTEM -- THAT THAT
THE STATE HAS HAD BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SURPLUS AND EXCEPT
FOR -- A BUMP UP TWO YEARS
AGO WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
AS AS AS ON GUY SAID IN ABOUT
SIXTEEN YEARS WE HAVE TO BE
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER -- TO TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE I KNOW THAT
I OFTEN HEAR THAT IT'S NOT --
POLITICIANS DON'T LIKE HEARING
FROM PROVIDERS BECAUSE WERE
SELF SERVING WILL IF IF IT'S
SELF SERVING TO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO DELIVER THE BEST QUALITY
SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
BY HIRING THE BEST QUALITY
STAFF THAN I AM SELF SERVING
AND I'M PROUD OF IT THANK YOU
WHERE YOU FROM MY NAME IS DAN
HOGAN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LAS TRAMPAS HERE IN LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA IT JUST DOWN THE
STREET LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA
I LIVE IN VALLEJO I'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS INDUSTRY
STARTED HIS DIRECT CARE STAFF
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE
AND I'VE SEEN A LOT OF CHANGES
TO THE SYSTEM IN ALL OF THESE
YEARS IT WAS A WONDERFUL SYSTEM
WHEN I FIRST ENTERED -- AND
I DON'T THINK THAT ANYBODY
HERE REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE
EROSION THAT HAS ACTUALLY
OCCURRED TO TO THIS TO THIS
-- SYSTEM SERVICES IN DAY
PROGRAMS WE PROVIDE DAY PROGRAM
INDEPENDENT LIVING SUPPORTED
LIVING AND ADULT RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
AS A LOSS OF THE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES -- WE'VE LOST SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST BECAUSE
WE CAN'T AFFORD THEM ANYMORE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS --
-- PT'S AS WELL -- MOBILITY
SERVICES AND WE'VE SEEN THIS
SERIOUS EROSION AND NOW WE'RE
LOSING OUR DIRECT CARE STAFF TO
MOVE OUT OF THE AREA AND MOVE
OUT OF STATE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE ANYMORE
WHEN I HAVE TO COUNSEL MY STAFF
LIKE I DO MANY OF OUR S.
L.
S.
LESSER I'LL AS CLIENTS ON HOW
TO FIND HOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT'S A SHAME THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO DESERVE FAR MORE IT SO
HOW DO WE AFFORD THIS SYSTEM
WELL I A ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
HAD ASKED YOU KNOW WHERE WE
CAN FIND THE FUNDING WELL --
SOME OF THE GENERIC RESOURCES
THAT WERE REQUIRED TO ACTUALLY
UTILIZE FIRST LIKE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES YOU KNOW THAT
IS A A NIGHTMARE AS A PROVIDER
TO ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT AND TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHO'S GOING
TO PAY OVERTIME AND WHEN ARE
WE GOING TO PAY THAT OVER TIME
AND SO FORTH IHS AS THE FUNDING
FOR I JUST ASKED FOR ID DE THAT
GENERIC RESOURCE REQUIREMENT
SHOULD JUST BE GONE AND LET
THE PROVIDERS ACTUALLY HANDLED
THAT DIRECTLY -- AND BECAUSE
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE NICE NIGHTMARE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
THAT SHOULD PROBABLY BE FUNDED
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FILTERED AWAY
FROM THE COUNTY SYSTEM AND
DIRECTLY INTO THE DD SYSTEM
-- WE SHOULD BE INCREASING
OUR EFFORTS AT RISK AT GETTING
MEDICAID FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF WE LOOK
AT THE STATISTICS CALIFORNIA
IS SIX ROUTINELY INSUFFICIENT
AND THE REQUIRING THOSE FUNDS
FOR THE ID BE COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S WHERE WE CAN GET A
LOT MORE DOLLARS IN -- ALSO
KEEP NOT JUST KEEPING THE DC
FUNDING THAT WE'RE SAVING FROM
INDIVIDUALS MOVING OUT BUT THE
SALE OF THE PROPERTIES SHOULD
STAY IN THE ID BE SERVICES
THIS SYSTEM AS WELL AND ALSO
REDUCING REDUNDANCIES WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE ALL OF OUR LICENSE
FACILITIES ARE UNDER TITLE
SEVENTEEN AND THE REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE TO DO A ON IT OUR
PROGRAMS AND THEN TITLE TWENTY
TWO COMMUNICATOR LICENSING HAS
TO DO THE SAME EXACT THING WHAT
ONE OF THEM NOT BOTH AND FILL
TO THOSE FUNDS TO US THANK YOU
NEWMAN REGION WHERE YOU FROM
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
-- MY NAME IS CARL LUNDEN
ABOUT LOBBYIST YOU GUYS KNOW
OPEN SACRAMENTO -- ONE THING
I DON'T SHARE VERY OFTEN SOME
ALSO FATHER OF A TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD -- WE'RE VERY CLOSE
TO ENTERING THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY
ESPECIALLY FOR YOU GUYS MAKING
THE TRIP I KNOW HOW HARD IT
IS A RITUAL YES MINUTE YEP I
JUST WANT TO LET THE AUDIENCE
KNOW EVERYBODY'S ON WIFI OVER
CRASH IN THE THE LIVE STREAM
SO LACKEY YOU SOMEBODY TO
TO SIGN OFF A LITTLE BIT SO
WE CAN AND OTHER PEOPLE THE
PUBLIC COULD UTILIZE THE THOUGH
THE LIFESTREAM I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT I APOLOGIZE FOR
IT REVENUE NO WORRIES THANK YOU
-- REALLY -- YOU INTERRUPTED
MY SAYING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND MAKE IN THE TIME OF
A TO -- IS SPECIALLY COMING
UP -- YOU KNOW FROM ACROSS
THE VALLEY IN FROM SAN JOSE IN
OTHER PLACES SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT IT'S I'VE BEEN A LOT
OF SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
MY THIRTY YEAR CAREER AS A
LOBBYIST AND THEY ARE ALWAYS
AS WELL ATTENDED SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT I'M GONNA TRY
TO MAKE THREE QUICK POINTS --
ON BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATION
I WORK WITH CALLED THE ALLIANCE
IT'S -- NETWORK A SMALL NETWORK
OF PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE
BUT SOME OF THIS REFLECT MY
VIEWS ON HAVING WORKED IN THIS
ISSUE OR FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AS
A LOBBYIST -- ONE THING YOU
HAVE THE -- AND I'LL TRY NOT
TO DO PLAY GROUND THAT'S BEEN
COVERED ONE THING THOSE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER IS A RATE STUDY
THIS COMING DO WE ARE STUDYING
-- IN THEORY WHAT IT COSTS TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES IN THE
SYSTEM THAT STUDY IS SUPPOSED
TO COME OUT SOMETIME IN MARCH
EXPERIENCE TELLS ME THAT THAT
STUDY MAY OR MAY NOT SHOW UP
ON TIME -- LET'S SAY IT DOESN'T
WORK IT SHOWS UP ON TIME THE
GAP BETWEEN THE TIME WHEN YOU
WOULD HAVE THE TIME TO REACT
AS A LEGISLATURE BETWEEN MARCH
AND MAY REVISED PUT SOMETHING
IN THE BUDGET THAT REFLECTS
INDIAN THAT REPORT IS HIGHLY
UNLIKELY SO ONE THING I THINK
YOU SHOULD SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
MOVING TO TRY TO DO IS TO PUT
IN PLACE SOME KIND OF BRIDGE
FUNDING REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE STUDY SAYS TO HELP THIS
COMMUNITY CONTINUE ON TO SOME
KIND OF FUTURE CONTEMPLATE
PUTTING SOME KIND OF FUNDING
IN IS A PLACEHOLDER FOR WHAT
WE'RE GONNA SEE THIS RATE
STUDY SECOND ISSUE THE WAITING
LIST THAT IS BEEN MENTIONED A
COUPLE TIMES WAITING LISTS ARE
TRICKY BECAUSE ONE PROGRAMS
OFTEN ARE GOING TO TELL YOU
THAT THEY HAVE A WAITING LIST
THAT DISCREDITS THEIR PROGRAM
THE SECOND THING IN THAT AREA
IS THAT AWAITING THIS CAN BE
ONE OF TWO THINGS ALSO IT CAN
BE A PERSON WHO YOU'RE WAITING
TO GIVE A SERVICE TO YOU DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF TO DO IT OR YOU
STICK HIM IN ANOTHER SERVICE
THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE UNTIL
THE RIGHT SERVICES AVAILABLE
FORM THAT'S ANOTHER FORM OF
HOW WAITING OCCURS LAST THING
ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
-- PIECE IN THE FUNDING YOU
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENED OVER TIME
IS THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT HAD
THE COURAGE TO STAND UP TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND IS LET THE
ADMINISTRATION RUN THE SHOW
ON THIS ISSUE I'VE WATCHED
STOCKTON DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AGNEW'S DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
CAMERI -- STATE HOSPITAL WHICH
HAD OUR CLIENTS IN IT AS WELL
LETTERMAN DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
EVERYONE OF THEM CLOSE NONE
OF THE ASSETS ARE OPERATING
DOLLARS WOULD TRANSFER TO THE
SYSTEM WE GET NO BENEFIT WHEN
THESE CLOTHES CENTER PEOPLE PUT
BACK IN THE COMMUNITY WHAT'S
HAPPENING TODAY IS YOU HAVE
TO FINAL DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
AND CLOSER HUGE ASSETS CINEMA
WOULD LIKE THAT PROPERTY STATE
CINEMAS WITH NOTHING ON IT IF
POSSIBLE MAKE THEM PAY FOR IT
LET'S GET SOMETHING OUT OF THAT
FAIRVIEW DOWN ORANGE COUNTY'S
ARE INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
PIECE OF PROPERTY THE SYSTEM
SHOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT IN
WE SHOULD ALSO BENEFIT BY
KEEPING THE OPERATIONS DOLLAR
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
OPERATING THOSE PROGRAMS TODAY
IN THE SYSTEM SERVING PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY THE AVERAGE
PERSON BED COST IN THE STATE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IS UP
AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A PERSON NOW HAVE YOU
IN THE COMMUNITY WE GET ABOUT
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON AVERAGE IT'S INEQUITABLE
MAKE IT WORK GRAB THAT MONEY
IN STAND UP AND FIGHT THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THE GIRL A LITTLE FRAYED
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS VERY
BEEN DONE I'M WITH BILLION
CORNERS WORRIED NONPROFIT
HOUSING -- DEVELOPER AND WE
PROVIDE HOUSING SERVICES --
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO -- I
HAVE -- WELL I PROBABLY WILL
USE MY THREE MINUTES BECAUSE
AUDRAN NICOLE IN JAN ALL GAVE
VERY GOOD DESCRIPTIONS OF
WHAT THE HOUSING SITUATION IS
IN THE ID THE FIELD -- I'VE
WORKED IN THIS FIELD ABOUT
FORTY THREE YEARS NOW AND WHAT
I'VE SEEN IS OVER THOSE YEARS
A NUMBER OF PARADIGM SHIFTS
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE
IN A PARADIGM SHIFT RELATED
TO HOUSING I THINK WELL WHAT
I SEE THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENED IS DUE TO
THE SUCCESS OF OTHER AREAS
OF A PERSON'S LIFE WEATHERBY
RECREATION OR EMPLOYMENT THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOVEMENT TOWARD
INTEGRATION AND FULL IN THE
INCLUSION AND THAT'S A GREAT
THING FOR ALL THE FOLKS WITH
ID DE THAT'S NOW HAPPENING
WITH HOUSING AND I THINK THAT'S
A WONDERFUL THING -- WE HAVE
LOTS OF PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW
THE NUMBERS BUT PROBABLY MORE
THAN HALF OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE BECOMING ADULTS TO DO NOT
WANT TO LIVE IN GROUP HOMES
THEY DO NOT WANT LIVING LICENSE
GROUP HOMES AND WHAT THEY'RE
WANTING OUR PLACES OF THEIR
OWN AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH WE KNOW THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
EVERYBODY LET ALONE THE PEOPLE
WITH THE ID DE WHO TENDED
NOT BE THE PEOPLE WHO GET ON
WAITING LISTS AND THAT KIND OF
THING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
-- JAN MENTIONED I THINK A
COUPLE GOOD SUGGESTIONS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE COULD BE DOING
-- ANOTHER ONE I WOULD I THINK
WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT IS
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF THE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES MOST OF THE PEOPLE
THE ADULTS WERE SERVING ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO NEED SOME
KIND OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE --
WE KNOW THE HEAD SECTION EIGHT
IS NOT GOING TO BE THE ANSWER
AND SAID -- SAN FRANCISCO
WE MAY PEOPLE PROBABLY READ
THAT HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN
DEBT TO BUY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS SO THERE'S NOT GONNA
BE SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS THERE
FOR PROBABLY THE REST OF MY
LIFE TIME BUT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT POSSIBILITIES OF HOW WE
CAN CREATE CREATIVELY -- RENT
SUBSIDIES FOR PEOPLE'S ID D.
R.
PROGRAM BREWING CORNERS WE
-- HAVE BRANCHED OUT AND
SURVIVE IT OTHER POPULATIONS
OUR BIGGEST PROGRAM IS IN
LOS ANGELES IT'S CALLED THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL
WE SERVE ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THROUGH THAT THAT
PROGRAM AND BASICALLY IT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
THIRTEEN OR MORE AGENCIES AT
THIS POINT HAVE POOLED THEIR
FUNDS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE A OPPORTUNITY A SUBSIDY
FOR INDIVIDUALS IT'S NOT
RELATED TO SECTION EIGHT OR
OTHER PUBLIC SUBSIDIES -- IN
I THINK AND IT'S WITH THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSION WITHIN
THE ID FIELD ABOUT LOOKING AT
THIS IS A MODEL I THINK WE NEED
TO LOOK AT DOES NEED TO LOOK
LIKE EXACTLY LIKE THE FLEXIBLE
HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL BUT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO SET UP SOME
KIND OF A SUBSIDY MECHANISM FOR
PEOPLE THAT ADD AND JUST THE
KIND OF A SIDE NOTE I WANT TO
THINK ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER OF
HEAT FOR HIS SUPPORT -- WE HAVE
A STATEWIDE COALITION CALLED
THE LETTERMAN HOUSING ALLIANCE
AND ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER
DELIVERED A VERY INSPIRATIONAL
PD -- SPEECH THERE ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AGO WE DEFINITELY
KNOW YOUR SUPPORT EVEN
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
THE SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE FROM
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS SERRA
VERITY I LIVE IN ANTELOPE BUT
I'M HERE REPRESENTING GATE
PASSED THE SERVICE PROVIDER
IN SAN MATEO AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- WE'RE APPROACHING A
ONE HUNDRED YEAR ANNIVERSARY
AND WE HOPE TO BE AROUND FOR
ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED YEARS
HOWEVER WE NEED RATE REFORM AND
THEN AT AND JUST CALLING DONT
WHAT DONNA SET AND REITERATE
WHAT DONNA MENTIONED AND I'M
SELF SERVING TO OUR DIRECT
CARE STAFF DESERVE BETTER
WAGES PARTICULARLY SAN MATTEO
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHERE AT
MINIMUM WAGE THE COST OF LIVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO OUR STAFF WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER MORE AND
I URGE YOU TO LOOK AT RATES
AND WE CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
RATE STUDY WE NEED MONEY NOW
NAME WHERE YOU'RE FROM GOOD
EVENING I'M CAROL MCKINNEY
I LIVE IN WALNUT CREEK
I AM THE CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HARMONY
HOME ASSOCIATED WE PROVIDE
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN SUPPORT
OF LIVING SERVICES IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY I'M ALSO THE
CO CHAIR OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK AND I WON'T REITERATE
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SAID BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH THEM OTHER THAN TO SAY
THAT WITHOUT A WORK FORCE AND
HOUSING PEOPLE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO LIVE AND PARTICIPATE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES -- THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO DO WAS
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA FOR
HIS STATEMENT THAT HE SUPPORTS
THE MONEY FROM THE DC CLOSURES
STAYING WITHIN OUR SYSTEM AND
I WANT TO LET HIM KNOW AND
AND ALL AND YOU KNOW AS WELL
THAT THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM WHO WILL SUPPORT
HIM WITHOUT FIGHT CURRENTLY
WE HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO DOESN'T
SEE IT THAT WAY AND WE LIKE TO
CHANGE THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHICH NAME WE'VE BEEN PLEASE A
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS GINNY OF AS THE ARE AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
FOR MODELS HOME CARE AND WE
PROVIDE MOSTLY RESPITE IN IOWA
SERVICES TO ROUGHLY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CLIENTS THROUGHOUT
THE EAST BAY I ALSO SERVE AS
ONE OF THE CO CHAIRS FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER OF THE EAST
BAY VENDOR ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MODELS HAS PARTNERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA RESPITE
ASSOCIATION TO COMMISSION ARE
MANY KNOW OF AN ACCOUNTING
FIRM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND GALLAGHER -- WORKFORCE
CONSERVATION FIRM TO DETERMINE
THE COST OF DELIVERING HOME
BASED DISABILITY SUPPORT
SERVICES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THIS IS AN ALTERNATIVE RATE
STUDIES WHAT BEING CURRENTLY
PROVIDED BY BIRDS AND
ASSOCIATES TO THE S.
WE ARE STUDYING RESPITE
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT
LIVING PERSON LISTENS IN
INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
INSTRUCTION SERVICES IN ORDER
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT PRICE
TO PAY DISABILITIES SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS FOR EACH SERVICE
WE DECIDED TO FIND OUT HOW
MUCH EACH PART OF THE SERVICE
COST TO DELIVER THE WAGES OF
STAFF THEIR BENEFITS OFFICE
IN TRAINING SPACE INSURANCE
PHONES COMPUTERS ETCETERA
WE FOUND OUT HOW MUCH THESE
RESOURCES COST BY RESEARCHING
THEIR PRICES WITHIN THE
MARKETPLACE WHERE DISABILITY
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS HIGHER
THEIR STAFF AND PAY FOR THEIR
BUSINESS QUITMAN AND RESOURCES
WITHIN THIS STUDY WE TAKE THE
OCCUPATIONS APPLICANTS CONSIDER
ALONGSIDE DISABILITY SERVICE
JOBS AND SEE HOW MUCH THEY
PAY WE USE THIS INFORMATION TO
CALCULATE HOW MUCH DISABILITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS WILL HAVE TO
PAPER LABOR COSTS GIVEN THAT
DIRECT SERVICE JOBS ARE OFTEN
MORE DEMANDING AND REQUIRE
MORE RESPONSIBILITY THE SAME
CALCULATION CONSIDERATIONS
WILL NEED TO BE MADE FOR
ORGANIZATION SUPERVISORS
TRAINERS AND MANAGERS AND OF
COURSE BESIDES EMPLOYEES THE
BUSINESS DISABILITY SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE TO PAY FOR
INSURANCE RANT PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES FOR ACCOUNTING TAXES
LAWYERS COMPUTER SOFTWARE
OFFICE SUPPLIES AND VARIETY OF
OTHER ITEMS THEN WHEN THE STATE
SET PRICES FOR SERVICES USING
A REAL COSTS CLIENTS IN THE
FAMILIES WILL BE ABLE TO CHOOSE
FROM SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS
COMPETING FOR THEIR BUSINESS
AND AS YOU HAVE HEARD THIS
EVENING IF PRICES ARE TOO LOW
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS WILL
STOP ACCEPTING NEW CLIENTS
STOP DEVELOPING NEW SERVICES
OR GO OUT OF BUSINESS WHICH
IS WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING
TODAY THE ONLY WAY TO CREATE
CLIENT CHOICE AND QUALITY THAT
FOLLOWS IS FOR THE STATE TO
SET PRICES BASED ON THE MARKET
COSTS LAST WEEK AT THE TOWN
HALL AND HE WORD WE RELEASE
PRELIMINARY DATA ON LOCAL
COSTS FOR RESPITE SERVICES
WE WILL CONTINUE TO RELEASE
DATA ON THE OTHER FOR SERVICE
CODES AS THEY ARE COMPLETED
WITH THE FINAL SIMILAR REPORT
HOPEFULLY TO BE RELEASED BY
THE END OF DECEMBER AND PLEASE
CONTACT US CONTACT US IF YOU
WOULD LIKE FURTHER INFORMATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE TWO NAME WE'RE FROM PLEASE
PERSONS WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE SIMPLY AND
HEARING OUR VOICES THIS EVENING
MY NAME IS JENNY WILCOX THE
CASE MANAGER AT THE ADAPTIVE
LEARNING CENTER HERE IN CONCORD
-- I'M HERE TODAY TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND FIGHT
FOR HIGHER WAGES FOR HUMAN
SERVICE WORKERS HERE'S WHY OUR
COST OF LIVING INDEX IS BASED
ON THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF ONE
HUNDRED CONTRA COSTA COUNTY'S
OVERALL COST OF LIVING IS A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE POINT
NINE NEARLY DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THE COST
OF LIVING HAS INCREASED AT ITS
FASTEST RATE IN TEN YEARS GAS
PRICES ALONE HAVE SURGED NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE POINT FOUR PERCENT
THIS PAST YEAR AND HOUSING
IS THE BIGGEST FACTOR IN THE
COST OF LIVING DIFFERENCE
MANY EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
HUMAN SERVICES ARE LOW WAGE
WORKERS IN CANNOT ADEQUATELY
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY ADEQUATELY
MAKE ENOUGH MONEY TO TO TO TO
PROVIDE THEIR FAMILY'S NEEDS
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
NEEDS I'M WORKING IN HUMAN
SERVICES CAN BE STRESSFUL AND
DEMANDING HUMAN SERVICE WORKERS
NEED A BROAD RANGE OF SKILLS
INTERPERSONAL SKILLS PROBLEM
SOLVING COMMUNICATION SKILLS
PATIENTS THE LIST GOES ON HUMAN
SERVICE WORKERS ARE COURAGEOUS
THEIR COMPASSIONATE WHICH
IS WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
RETAIN AND PROVIDE THE QUALITY
SUPPORTS THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES RELY SO HEAVILY
UPON MANY FAST FOOD CHAINS HAVE
STARTING WAGES A QUICK LENT
OR HIGHER TO THOSE WORKING IN
HUMAN SERVICES AND YOU DON'T
NEED TO BE HIGHLY SKILLED TO
WORK IN A FAST FOOD CHAINS
SUCH AS IN AND OUT BURGER
STARBUCKS JUMBA JUICE WHERE
WAGES START OUT THE SAME AS AS
HUMAN SERVICE WORKERS SOMETIMES
HIGHER OR EQUIVALENT SO THAT'S
CONCERNING ITS CONCERNING ON
A VARIETY OF LEVELS ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT RETENTION
A HIGH TURNOVER RATE IMPACTS
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SUPPORT
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE THIS
EVENING I'M HERE TO TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR HIGHER
WAGES FOR HUMAN SERVICE
WORKERS TO RETAIN QUALITY
EMPLOYEES THAT OFFER ADEQUATE
SUPPORTS THE INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORT RELY UPON SO THANK YOU
PLEASE -- NAME IS -- JAMES
HERE MOTO I LIVE IN BRENTWOOD
AND I'M A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
WITH THE PLAN WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WORK RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM MY LIVE RIGHT
ACROSS STREET FROM WHERE I WORK
-- -- MY BACKGROUND IS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST BEEN DOING THAT
FOR ALMOST TWENTY PLUS YEARS
I'VE ALSO BEEN -- WORK FOR
THE DIAGNOSTIC CENTER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FREMONT PART OF THIS
-- CALIFORNIA PART OF EDUCATION
SEVEN YEARS THEN PROFESSOR AND
A PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR SEVEN
PLUS YEARS AND BEEN ELECTED
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER TWICE
-- DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
SOMETHING KNOWN VERY WELL --
GIVEN THAT -- I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT GETTING FUNDING FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS EARLY EARLY
IDENTIFICATION EARLY EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY BIRTH
TO THREE IF WE DON'T GET THEM
OR IF THEY DON'T GET SERVICES
EARLY IT TAKES THAT MUCH LONGER
FOR THE BENEFITS TO OCCUR
THAT'S WHERE IT SO THERE'S A
DOMINO EFFECT IF THEY DON'T GET
THE FUNDING IT'LL IMPACT THE
SCHOOLS AND THEN THE SCHOOLS
HAVE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
LONGER AND MORE IMPACTED SO
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS DESPERATELY NEED THIS
AND THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
HUGE GIGANTIC CASELOADS THAT
THAT'S IN A LOT OF TURNOVER
THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE KIDS TURNING
THREE YET SOMETIMES AND GET
US THAT INFORMATION RIGHT AWAY
WHERE WE ARE REQUIRED BY LAW
TO DO THE ASSESSMENTS AND THEN
LEGAL THINGS START HAPPENING
WITH SCHOOLS -- IT WAS BY THAT
THAT -- BY ABA SERVICES AND
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE MANDATED ONCE
YOU HAVE AN ID P.
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE THAT'S
THAT'S IT SCHOOL DISCRIMINATED
BRED PROVIDE SERVICES -- IF
THE NEED IS THERE AND SOME
DISTRICTS BECAUSE OF LEGAL
ISSUES ARE ARE ARE LOCAL TO TWO
TO FORM THAT OUT THEY TRY TO DO
IT IN HOUSE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
-- WE WE HAVE THE CBA'S WE HAVE
BEHAVIOR TAX IN BE INVENTED
-- MY CONCERN WITH THE CURRENT
FUNDING FORMULA FOR EDUCATION
HERTZ GROWING DISTRICTS LIKE
BRENT WOULD BRENTWOOD HAS ONE
OF THE LOWEST EIGHTY EIGHT
BASE RATES IN THE STATE IF
YOU LOOK IT UP YET OUR HOUSING
COSTS ARE ASTRONOMICAL SO ONE
WOULD THINK THAT HOUSING COSTS
SCHOOLS GET FUNDING NOW IT'S
NOT THAT IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE
-- AND THIS IS LIKE LAMMERS
VILLE AND MOUNT HOUSE FALLING
TO THE SAME RAPID GROWTH IN AN
AGRARIAN AREA FUNDING SOURCES
ARE REALLY MINIMAL FOR THE
SCHOOLS IT CAN BE AS MUCH
AS TWO HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER STUDENT DIFFERENCE
SOME EVEN FAR GREATER THAN
THAT SO THAT'S SOMETHING
I'M HOPING THAT WILL HAPPEN
WITH THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THE NAME REFERS AND FROM ON THE
CREEK -- I WORK FOR COMMUNITY
INNOVATIVE WORK PROGRAMMING
WE PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA -- I'M RUNNING
PROGRAMS HERE IN THE EAST BAY
-- BUT I'M ALSO HERE -- AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR FAMILY MEMBER WITH
AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY --
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU AN ELEVATOR
PITCH -- SO -- I GOT THIS JOB
OPPORTUNITY IT'S IT'S VERY
SPECIAL IS VERY VERY REWARDING
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE
TO HELP SOMEBODY WITH THEIR
SELF CARE BUT IN ADDITION --
EXPECT TO BE YELLED AT EXPECT
TO BE THREATENED YOU MIGHT GET
SLAPPED YOU MIGHT GET PUNCHED
IN MY GET YOUR HAIR PULLED
-- AND THEN AT THE END OF THE
DAY YOU HAVE TO DETERMINE AM
I GONNA BE ABLE TO COME BACK
AGAIN TOMORROW CAN I FOR TO
COME BACK AGAIN TOMORROW OR DO
I GET A JOB FLIPPING BURGERS
AS PEOPLE SAID DRIVING FOR UBER
-- -- THAT THAT IS THE REALITY
AND I'M LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
I I COULD HAVE ANY MY STAFF
HERE WHO HAVE FACES ISSUES
BECAUSE THEIR HOME GETTING
THE REST THEY'RE GONNA COME
BACK AGAIN AND DO IT TOMORROW
AND I'M SO THANKFUL TO THEM
BUT THEY DESERVE MORE THEY
DESERVE MORE AND MY FAMILY
MEMBER WITH AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY HAS SOME SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES -- BUT THE PERSON
WHO CARES FOR HIM -- HAD TO
QUIT THEIR JOB BECAUSE IN THIRD
FRESNO WE'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND
SERVICES THERE WAS NOBODY WHO
CAN PROVIDE US WITH A NEED SO
HE'S RECEIVING PUBLIC SERVICES
NOW HIS FATHER'S RECEIVE
PUBLIC SERVICES SO THAT'S ON
ON ANTICIPATED CONSEQUENCES
BUT IT'S A REALITY THEY'RE NOT
THE WORKERS THERE'S NOT THE
WORK FORCE -- BECAUSE PEOPLE
JUST CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THE
WORK THEY WANT TO BUT THEY
CAN'T THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
THEIR EXACT MAN I HAVE THE
DISTINCT HONOR AND THE DISTINCT
CHALLENGE TO BE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GOLDEN GATE
REGIONAL CENTER WE SERVE ABOUT
ONE LAUGH WE SERVE ABOUT NINETY
SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE AND SAN
MATTEO SAN FRANCISCO IN MARIN
COUNTIES -- EARLIER SPEAKER
TALKED ABOUT THE PERCENTAGE
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF
COST OF LIVING -- WE'RE BETWEEN
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY AND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
MARIN COUNTY IS NOW MY AN
EXPENSIVE COUNTY WHICH I TAKE
NOTE AND IN GLEE OF OF TELLING
THEM -- SO I WORK IN THE FIELD
FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS MOSTLY
WITH PROVIDER STARTED IN DIRECT
SERVICE IN A SHELTERED WORKSHOP
AND WORKED IN SUPPORT OF LIVING
IN RESIDENTIAL AND -- RESPITE
AN AFTER SCHOOL RECREATION --
AND I'VE BEEN WITH THE GOLDEN
GATE REGIONAL CENTER NOW FOR
ON ON COMING ON THREE YEARS
AND I LOVE TO TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND CIVIL RIGHTS THAT'S
ONE FROM TRUMAN IN THE FIELD
BUT I'M REALLY GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE TWO STRUCTURAL THINGS
THAT I THINK ARE GOING TO MAKE
THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE IN THE
NEXT DECADES WHICH IS -- MEDIAN
RATES AND -- THE FUNDING OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AND TO TRY
TO ADD SOMETHING HOPEFULLY NEW
TO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT --
MEDIAN RATES IT'S NOT A NEW
IDEA FOR CALIFORNIA -- WHEN I
WAS -- STARTED OUT AND THROUGH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN DIFFERENT
WAYS THERE WAS A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE COST OF PROVIDING
SUPPORT IN THE RATES THAT WERE
PAID FOR SUPPORT WILL AND I
AM PROBABLY ONE OR TWO OTHER
PEOPLE REMEMBER COST STATEMENTS
WERE YOU IN FOR PROVIDERS ARE
YOU RECORDED HOW MUCH IT COSTS
THAT WERE ALLOWABLE COSTS HE
DIVIDED BY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
YOU SERVED IT WASN'T A PERFECT
SYSTEM BUT YOU IT WAS CONNECTED
TO WHAT IT COSTS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES -- AND SO THAT ENDED
IN NINETY SIX NINETY SEVEN FOR
THE BIG SERVICES AND THEN IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS LOS THE FLEXIBILITY
TO GO NEGOTIATE RATES AND
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN COSTS
AND RATES FELL AWAY SOMEWHERE
TALKING ABOUT RATE INCREASES
IT'S NOT AND IT RATE INCREASES
JUST HAVING SOME RATIONAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN WHAT THE
COSTS ARE AND WHAT THE SERVICES
ARE -- REALLY QUICKLY WITH
THE LAST THING ON MEDIAN RATES
AS I HAD A PROVIDER FROM THIS
AREA WHO HAS ONE OF THE MOST
ROBUST -- PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND RATES IN OUR AREA AND SHE
WENT TO US DESPERATE FOR STAFF
YOU INTO A JOB FAIR IN TROUBLE
TODAY WAS PLAYING HIGHER THAN
SHE COULD OFFER -- AS HER
ENTRY LEVEL AND THAT SERVING
FOLKS WITH SIGNIFICANT NEEDS
AGAIN THAT THROUGH RATES THAT
ARE ON THE HIGHER END OF OUR
RATES REGION CENTER FUNDING
IS BASICALLY SAID SAID ON --
MECHANISM FROM THE MID EIGHTIES
THAT HAS AGAIN NO CONNECTION
WITH COSTS AND WE DEARLY LOVE
OUR COLLEAGUE HEATHER FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT WE GET
THE SAME AMOUNT FOR THE CASE
MANAGERS AND I'VE GOLDEN GATE
WE'VE GOT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE STAFF AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY OR SEVENTY CASE
MANAGERS CAN MAKE TWENTY TO
THIRTY PERCENT MORE WORKING
FOR GOVERNMENT WORKING FOR
THE COUNTIES AS SOCIAL WORKERS
THEY STAY WITH US BECAUSE
THEY LOVE THE FAMILIES AND THE
INDIVIDUALS THEY SERVE AND ARE
CONNECTED TO THEM AND BUT WE
CAN DRIVE THEM AWAY IF THEY
COULD JUST CANCER FIVE IN OUR
AREA -- SO I'D LOVE TO TALK TO
MORE ABOUT THOSE THINGS -- BUT
I MEANT ZERO SO I'M GOING TO
SAY THAT THE LANHAM ACT AS ITS
VERY CORE IS ABOUT EQUAL ACCESS
NOT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
EQUAL ACCESS TO LIVE WORK AND
PLAY AND AS PEOPLE WITHOUT
TO ABILITIES TO AND THE FIRST
LINE IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ACCEPTS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEIR CITIZENS IN THERE AND
-- COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL AND INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND AT SOME POINT
WITH THE SEVERE UNDERFUNDING
CALIFORNIA'S NO LONGER
ACCEPTING THAT RESPONSIBILITY
AND I IT'S GONNA TAKE EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM TO ADVOCATE
FOR THOUSANDS OF THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE YOU
AND MY NAME IS CHRISTINE MCCANN
AND I AM FROM ANY ARGUMENT
BRAND NEW RESIDENT OF ANTIOCH
HAVING MOVED FROM NEW YORK AND
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND BOTH
HAVE AUTISM MY SON TYLER IS
NINETEEN AND WE JUST DROPPED
HIM OFF AT UC SANTA CRUZ TO
STUDY MICROBIOLOGY AND HE HAS
REQUIRED A RANGE OF SERVICES
SPEECH LANGUAGE -- T.
ABA AND THREE SCHOOL OUR S.
P.
FOR EXTENSIVE TUTORING FOR
LEARNING DISABILITY AND HIS
HOPE IS TO GO ON AND STUDY AND
VIRUSES AND GOING TO MEDICAL
RESEARCH AND MY YOUNGER SON
HUNTER MS FOURTEEN AM AM THREE
REGIONAL HAS INSTITUTIONAL
TEAMING ARMY AND IT IS AT TIMES
EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE AND WE HAD
AN INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING REGIONAL TO ACCEPT HIM
I HAVE CALLED SEVERAL TIMES
AND WHEN HE WAS YOUNGER BEFORE
DIAGNOSIS AND TELLING THEM
WE ARE IN CRISIS MODE WE NEED
HELP WE COULD NOT GET SERVICES
THREE INSURANCE -- AND EACH
TIME I CALLED REGIONAL SAID
WELL IT'S A SIX MONTH WAIT
AND YOU PROBABLY WON'T GET IT
YOU DON'T HAVE A DIAGNOSIS TRY
SOMEWHERE ELSE TRY YOU HEALTH
INSURANCE HIGH SCHOOL WHEN WE
DID FINALLY GET REGIONAL CENTER
AND I'D ALREADY GONE TO UNITED
HEALTHCARE AND BEEN DENIED
A DOZEN TIMES AND FINALLY
ENDED UP TAKING THEM TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE WITH THE AND ASSISTANCE OF
STD CONSULTANTS WHO PROVIDED A
FULL SCOPE FTA TO FIGHT UNITED
HEALTHCARE WE ONE SERVICES IT
WASN'T UNTIL THEN THAT REGIONAL
CENTER FINALLY ACCEPTED US ONLY
WITH DOING THEIR OWN ASSESSMENT
TO SEE IF HE QUALIFIED WITH
SEVERAL DIAGNOSIS IN PLACE AM I
HEAR THAT THEY PROVIDE TONS OF
SERVICES WE HAVE YET TO SEE A
MAJORITY OF THOSE SERVICES ANY
HERE THAT THEY'RE REQUESTING
FUNDING BUT I'M NOT SURE WHERE
THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING BECAUSE
I DON'T FEEL THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO WRECK THE TO THE FAMILIES
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHERE THOSE
FUNDS ARE GOING TO SEE THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO THE FEES
ARE THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
IT IS BUT I WANT TO SEE THE
TRICKLE DOWN TO THE FAMILIES
HUNTER WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW
IN HIS BROTHER'S FOOTSTEPS
BUT WITHOUT SERVICES WITHOUT
YOU KNOW SUPPORT FROM REGIONAL
AND ALL THESE PUBLIC FUNDS WE
CAN'T DO THAT AT ONE POINT I
HAD TWO BOYS AND A BE A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK IN
COPAYMENTS THAT'S TWO THOUSAND
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER MONTH OUT OF OUR POCKET
JUST TO GET THEM TO CO HAVE
A TAPE TO MAKE SURE I'M NOT
GETTING STABBED OR CHOKED
OR HAIR PULLED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR SON CAN REMAIN IN
OUR HOME SO I'M ASKING THAT
YOU LOOK AT THE WHERE THESE
FUNDS ARE GOING FOR REGIONAL
CENTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
NAMELY FROM HI MY NAME IS RENEE
CALLAWAY I'M FROM OAKLEY AND
MY SON JEREMY IS TEN YEARS OLD
AND -- HE IS A RECIPIENT OF
MEDICAID AND ALSO A REGIONAL
CENTER OF THE EAST BAY CONSUMER
FOR THE LAST EIGHT AND HALF
YEARS I IN JANUARY WE MET WITH
HIS CASE WORKER FOR HIS ANNUAL
VISIT AND AT THAT TIME THE CASE
WORKER SAID HE DID NOT QUALIFY
FOR SERVICES I THEN ASKED THE
CASE WORKER WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF HAVING THESE ANNUAL VISITS
IF HE DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR
SERVICES -- SHE REPLIED JUST
TO KEEP THEM IN THE SYSTEM IN
APRIL I REACHED BACK OUT TO MY
CASE MANAGER BECAUSE JEREMY'S
BEHAVIORS STARTED BECOMING
INCREASINGLY MORE VIOLENT
TOWARDS ME -- I WAS FEARFUL
FOR HIS SAFETY MY SAFETY AND
-- OTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY
SAFETY -- THE CASE MANAGER
CAME BACK INTO THE HOME AND
AT THAT POINT HE QUALIFIED FOR
RESPITE SERVICES AND -- BEFORE
SHE LEFT SHE SAID SHE'S GOING
TO MAIL ME APPEAL LESS -- THAT
WAS APRIL WE ARE IN OCTOBER
I STILL DO NOT HAVE APPEAL
LESS I SAT HERE LISTEN TO LISA
TALK ABOUT ALL THE WONDERFUL
SERVICES THAT REGIONAL CENTER
PROVIDES -- THE FIRST SERVICE
LISTED ON HERE IS ADVOCACY
MY EXPERIENCES IN THE
EXPERIENCES OF OTHER PARENTS
THAT I HAVE SPOKEN TO WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE SERVICES
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW NINE
I'M KINDA ECHOING THE LAST
SPEAKER'S COMMENTS WHERE IS
THE MONEY GOING -- BECAUSE
IT'S A GOING TO THE ADMIN
ADMIN COSTS IS IT GOING TO
ADVOCATING FOR SERVICES -- THAT
DON'T EXIST WE'RE NOT SEEING
IT THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO HOLD THESE HEARINGS
AND THEN GIVING A VOICE TO
THOSE WHO SO OFTEN GO LEFT ON
HEARD OR UNSPOKEN OUT OF FEAR
OF LOSING SERVICES THAT THEY
POSSIBLY CAN GET THANK YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND ONE
HI MY NAME IS SHARED IN THE
CLOUD AND THE REGIONAL MANAGER
FOR THE BAY AREA OFFICE OF THE
STATE COUNCIL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO FOR BEING HERE AND
REPRESENTING SELECT COMMITTEE
I'M ALSO HERE WITH OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF POLICY CINDY SMITH
AND OUR NORTH BAY REGIONAL
MANAGER LISA HOOKS FROM STATE
COUNCIL AND -- WE ARE SO
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
THIS COMMUNITY AND STAND SIDE
BY SIDE AND FIGHT HAND IN HAND
WITH SELF ADVOCATES FAMILY
ADVOCATES AND PROFESSIONALS
IN THE FIELD TO MAKE SURE THAT
DISABILITY RIGHTS ARE SEEN
AS WHAT THEY ARE CIVIL RIGHTS
HUMAN RIGHTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S EQUITY AN OPPORTUNITY
AND RESPECT AND THAT WE CAN
PUT TOGETHER AND GLUED BACK
TOGETHER AT A SYSTEMS THAT'S
FUNCTIONING THE WAY THAT IT'S
INTENDED I WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU THIS EVENING WITHIN
ALL TWELVE REGIONAL OFFICES OF
THE STATE COUNCIL ACROSS THE
STATE WE HAVE REGIONAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEES MADE UP OF SELF
ADVOCATES FAMILY OUT BECAUSE
AS WELL AS PROFESSIONALS IN
THE FIELD WORKING TOGETHER
IDENTIFYING TRENDS IDENTIFY
NEEDS AND IDENTIFYING SOLUTIONS
-- EARLIER YOUR OFFICE RECEIVED
A SUMMARY OF THAT PORTRAIT OF
SERVICES SEGMENT WE DO THAT
EVERY YEAR IT'S ONE OF THE
MANY THINGS THAT ARE REGIONAL
BY THREE COMMITTEES DO IN
ADDITION TO PUBLIC MEETINGS
AND A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT --
ANALYSIS WORK IN FEEDBACK WORK
FOR THE COMMUNITY I WANTED TO
READ JUST THE TOP PRIORITIES
AND IDENTIFIED NEEDS BASED ON
THE REGIONAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR THE BAY AREA OFFICE MAKING
UP THE FIVE COUNTIES HERE IN
THE BAY AREA THEY IDENTIFIED
AFFORDABLE INCLUSIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEY RECOGNIZED
THE NEED FOR PROPER FUNDING FOR
SERVICES SUPPORTS AND SERVICE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PEOPLE WITH
ADD TO REPAIR THE HURT THAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE MANY DECADES
OF CUTS DIMENSION EMPLOYMENT
OPTIONS EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS
FOR COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER FOR
THE WONDERFUL WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE THIS LAST LEGISLATIVE
SESSION IS MANY OTHERS WHEN IT
COMES TO COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS
THIS THEY ALSO IDENTIFIED
ACCESS TO GENERIC SERVICES
LIKE RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION
WHICH YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THIS EVENING AS WELL AS IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES OTHER GENERIC
SERVICES THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THIS ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO PUT THIS PUZZLE PIECES
TOGETHER AN ADEQUATE TRANSITION
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO
PREPARE YOUTH WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
FOR SUCCESSFUL ADULTHOOD SO
THAT MEANS INCLUSIVE OF FAIR
AND APPROPRIATE EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT THE EDUCATIONAL
LIFESPAN OF AN INDIVIDUAL AND
THEN SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
SERVICES FOR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING AND A FULL WRAP AROUND
SUPPORTS IS NEEDED SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN LIVE THE LIFE THAT
THEY CHOOSE AND -- JUST WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT WE LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUING TO WORK IN
THE WORKING WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IN THE OFFICE AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THIS COMMUNITY -- I'M A FAMILY
ADVOCATE FIRST AND FOREMOST WAS
A PROVIDER FOR MANY YEARS NOW
WORKING WITH THE STATE COUNCIL
AND -- IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ABLE TO WORK SIDE BY SIDE WITH
THIS COMMUNITY YOU SEE THIS
EVENING THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE REFER THEM WE FROM
PLEASE YES MY NAME IS JOHN
MCCUE I LIVE IN CINEMA COUNTY
AND WORKING WITH SOME FOLKS
IN MARIN COUNTY CURRENT --
CURRENTLY -- I'D FIRST LIKE
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION TO
ALL THE SPEAKERS AT THAT WOULD
A FIRM -- EVERYTHING YOU'VE
HEARD TONIGHT IN TERMS OF
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK -- -- THE
THE MATTER OF -- THE NEED FOR
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
-- FOR FOLKS -- PARTICULARLY
LICENSED HOUSING THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION HOMES THAT WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA DEVELOP TO A SYSTEM
THAT RELIED ON PROPRIETARY
OWNERSHIP OF THEN PROPRIETORS
OF THOSE HOME SAID THEY WERE
FOR PROFIT -- HOMES AND PART OF
THE COVERAGE IN IN OF TRACTION
OF OFFERING THAT SERVICE WAS
THE POTENTIAL OF EQUITY IN THE
HOMES BECAUSE THE BUSINESSES
OWNED THOSE -- HOUSES AND AND
-- WE'RE LOSING THAT I'VE BEEN
IN THE FIELD FOR ACTUALLY FIFTY
YEARS -- THIS YEAR AND I HAVE
OVER THE LAST DECADE OBSERVED
-- INCREASING NUMBERS OF HOMES
THAT WERE GENERATED AS PEOPLE
LEFT THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN THE SEVENTIES EIGHTIES
AND NINETIES -- AS THOSE
PROPRIETORS RETIRED THOSE HOMES
WERE SOLD AND FOR THE MOST PART
ONE WAY -- IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
PERMANENT HOUSING PICKING UP
ON -- COMMENT YOU HEARD EARLIER
WE HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
THAT ARE BEING -- EMPTIED IN
-- CLOSE THOSE ARE EXTREMELY
POOR -- VALUABLE RESOURCES
THEY WERE STABILISED IN THE
CASE OF CINEMA HUNDRED YEARS
AGO FOR PERMANENT HOUSING FOR
PERMANENT TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT WOULD BE
-- THE FUNDING FOR PERMANENT
RESIDENTIAL HOMES USING A BUY
IT NOW AND AS THE STATE'S BEEN
DOING WITH A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHERE THE STATE FRANCE
THE MONEY TO PURCHASE THE
HOME AND -- TURNS OVER THE
HOME TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION IN ORDER FOR TO
BE ESTABLISHED AS PERMANENT
HOUSING AND -- WE BUY IT ONCE
AND THEN THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
WILL PAY THE THE RENT AND
WE'LL HAVE THAT HOUSING LASTING
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
USE THE TWO NAME ARE YOU MY
NAME IS PAMELA MITCHELL AND
I'M A CO FOUNDER BE WALKER
RANCH IT IS A WORKING WE ARE
BUILDING A WORKING RANCH AND
FARMING DAY PROGRAM IN SYSOON
VALLEY -- THIS LISTENING
TO THE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
IN THE ROOM -- WE'RE VERY
AWARE THAT SUSTAINABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS -- FOR FRONT
PROBLEM FOR THE THIS THIS
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE GOING ON
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC AND WE ARE OUT
TO KIND OF MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THAT IN OUR OUR MODEL OUR
MODEL PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
BE SELF SUSTAINABLE ONCE WE
ARE BUILT AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT THE PROGRAMS IN PLACE
IN THE WORKSHOPS IN PLACE CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE EPIDEMIC
ISSUES WE HAVE ADDRESS SOME OF
THE -- WORKSHOPS THAT NEED TO
BE HELD FOR FIRST RESPONDERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT EDUCATIONAL
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL AND WE ARE
JUST LOOKING FOR A CLEAR PATH
AND SUPPORT FOR THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM IN OUR DISTRICT AND
JUST WANTED TO INTRODUCE THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SIX MEMORY FROM PLEASE
GOOD EVENING RICHARD CALHOUN
WITH CEDAR FROM SAN JOSE
CEDARS COALITION OF ELDER IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS WE FOCUS ON
THE RIGHTS THE ALTAR IN THIS
ABILITIES FOR THE MOST PART THE
LAWS OF THE SAME I'M HERE FOR
A COUPLE LAST YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO ASK YOUR COLLEAGUES
TO HELP YOU OUT THREE KAY LÀ
COMMITTEE THREE J.
LACK REQUEST IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND TWENTY BILLS GET
THE DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR
AND LET'S HAVE A DISCUSSION
WITH A PASS OR FAIL WILL GET
YOUR CALL WORKERS VOTE ON
THESE ISSUES I'D BE TALKING
TO YOUR OFFICES IN FACT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU MISTER FRAZIER
I LEARNED ABOUT THIS MEETING
WHEN I WAS WALKING THE CAPITAL
ON MONDAY YOUR OFFICE STAFF
WASN'T AVAILABLE BUT TELL
ME ABOUT THIS MEETING WILL
BE UP THERE ON WEDNESDAY AND
THURSDAY SO THAT'S THE ASK THE
HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT TEXAS LAW
REVIEW DOT COM SLASH FLEXIBLE
I'D DAY EIGHT DOLLARS FOR DOWN
ITS YOU HAVEN'T EVEN HEARD OF
THE COMPANY CALLED LIKE SIMPLE
UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD OF THEM THEY RELEASED A
PEER REVIEWED JOURNAL ARTICLE
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THAT FAIRLY RECENT THEY
FOUND OUT THAT NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THIS STATE USE A
PRIVATE COMPANY THAT SECRET
NO PUBLIC INPUT TO WRITE THE
PUBLIC POLICIES FOR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THEIR SOLE FOCUS
IS REDUCING LIABILITY NOTHING
ABOUT PROVIDING GOOD SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE THEY RECOMMEND THAT
OFFICE AT THAT AGENCIES TAKE
PROTECT AND SERVE OFF THEIR
PATROL CARS BECAUSE HAVING
THAT LANGUAGE ON THE PATROL
CAR'S RAISES THE LIABILITY TO
THE AGENCY I THINK IT'S TIME
THAT WE CALL A BOWL OF BULL
AND SAY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE GIVEN UP THE
RIGHT FOR LOCAL CONTROL LET'S
COME UP WITH A STATE POLICY
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES CAN ADOPT
THAT BALANCE GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
WITH GOOD LIABILITY THERE'S A
BALANCING ACT IT'S NOT SOLELY
LIABILITY THE NEXT ISSUE IS
WHY DOES THE STATE TELL US
TO CALL IT DON'T PROTECTIVE
SERVICE WHEN WE SEE AN CRIME
AGAINST THE DISABILITY PERSON
IF YOU SEE SOMEONE ROBBING A
BANK RECALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE SHOULD BE CALLING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF WE SEE ABUSE OF
AN ELDER OR DISABILITY PERSON
NOT SOCIAL WORKERS THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING
THIS STATE AND THE NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AT THE STATE
LEGISLATION WITH LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUAL THE
AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
SURE THERE WAS TO WELL I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ONE AN
INDIVIDUAL JOSTLE THAN WHO
OVER THE YEARS I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HE'S
BEEN A MENTOR TO ME IN A GO
TO ALSO ALONG WITH WILL AND
SOME OF THE OTHER MEMBERS IN
IN THE IN THE AUDIENCE BUT
OF JUST BECAUSE HE'S A ALWAYS
BEEN THERE WHEN I'VE ASKED A
QUESTION ALSO TRACY OVER THE
ARK IS BEEN A WONDERFUL SOURCE
OF INFORMATION ALSO I WILL
TELL YOU THAT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT INTEGRATED WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE DID THE BILL
THIS YEAR AND IT WAS -- NOT
WELL RECEIVED BY THE AGENCIES
BUT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARDS THAT EFFORT -- MY
OFFICE ALONE JUST DID THIRTY
THOUSAND RED RIBBONS WITH THE
ARK OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WE
HIRED THEM TO DO THAT FOR US
THAT WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE SCHOOLS I'M GOING TO LOOK
TOWARDS THE LEGISLATURE TO
ANY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN
TO BE ABLE TO EMPLOY THESE A
PROVIDERS OF SERVICES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND GO
FORWARD WE ALSO AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE INTERNS ARE OFFICES
IN OUR DISTRICT AND ALSO IN
OUR CAPITOL OFFICE AND IT'S
STARTING TO SPUR IS BECOMING
INFECTION THING -- IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- MIKE GIPSON
NOW IN HIS DISTRICT UTILIZES OF
AN INTERN WHO HAS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SO WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS MOVING THAT FOR MISTER
HAS CHIU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
THE CLOTHES GREAT AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER FOR SIR FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY ALTHOUGH I'M LATE
BUT I FELT THAT I DIDN'T MISS
A DAY OF THE BEST PART OF
TODAY'S HEARING AND BE ABLE
TO HEAR THE PUBLIC COMMENTS I
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK THE LIKE -- AND THOSE
CONSUMERS THAT COME FORWARD
AND SHARE YOUR EXPERIENCES AS
WELL AS THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
YOU KNOW I I HAD THE CHANCE TO
TOUR OF THE DAFT'S -- SCHOOL
IN FREMONT IS THE STORY HERE
AND NOW HE'S SHE SHE LEFT
ALREADY YOU OWES VERY VERY
IMPRESSIVE -- -- OPERATION HE
GOT ALL DEAR IN THE INDUSTRIAL
PARK AREA -- WHEN I WAS FIRST
ELECTED I SERVE AS A CHAIR OF
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
FOR TWO YEARS AND -- AFTER THIS
HEARING I'M CONSIDERING GOING
BACK TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE OF COME NEXT -- A
SESSION SO THANK YOU AGAIN
JONES FORD FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND -- ONCE THANK EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE A PARTICIPATING
CONCORD'S REGIONAL HEARING --
I LOVE MEETING YOUR HEARING
-- WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY -- I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
FOR YOUR INSIGHT AND SUPPORT
ON BEING HERE TODAY I'D LIKE
TO SAY GOOD NIGHT TO ALL BUT
PLACE JUST SAYING THAT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE THE SYSTEM
IS ENTERED FLUCTUATING LEVELS
OF SUPPORT IN THE STATE OVER
THE PAST DECADE GET THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS IDT CONTINUES TO
RISE OVER THE LAST DECADE AND
IT HAD AN AVERAGE INCREASE RATE
OF THREE POINT SEVEN PERCENT
ANNUALLY WE'VE SEEN ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW CONSUMERS
ENTER THE SYSTEM MORE THAN
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND NOW BEING SERVICE
SO WE SHOULD EXPECT TO SEE
MORE WELL WE HAVE SEEN RECENT
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS TO THE
SYSTEM TO MEET NEEDS S.
JUST A TEMPORARY FIX TO OUR
LONG LASTING PROBLEMS I THINK
WE ALL AGREE THAT THE SYSTEM
NEEDS FUNDING I MEAN THAT'S
WHAT IS PREVALENT TERMS BEEN
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE HERE TONIGHT
I STILL WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PARTICIPATE IN A SURVEY
OF FAMILIES BEING SERVICED
BY THE SYSTEM YOU CAN FIND A
LINK TO THE SURVEY ON THE SLOW
SIDE COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WEBSITE LOOK FOR THE HAND OUT
ON THE TABLE ON YOUR WAY OUT
FOR THE LINK TO THE SURVEY
WITH YOUR INPUT WE WILL LEARN
MORE ABOUT YOU AND YOUR NEEDS
WE'RE THAT WE ARE ONLY STRONGER
TOGETHER WORKING TOGETHER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND I
WILL TELL YOU WE THROUGH THE
SURVEY WE'VE HAD PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT FEAR OF RETRIBUTION OF
FOR BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY IN
PUBLIC WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
SAYING THAT THERE'S THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING SERVICES
AND LISTEN I HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE AGAIN WELL
INTENTIONED THE THE FUNDING
IS AN ISSUE MAKING SURE THAT
THE CASE MANAGERS CAN HAVE
THE ABILITY THEY'RE LOADED
THEIR THEIR NINETY SOME HAVE
NINETY THREE OF CONSUMERS GOING
FORWARD WE NEED TO WORK ON THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THE REGIONAL
SERVICE OF THE MONEY BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S AN
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THROUGH THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED THAT
THE PEOPLE GET EVERYTHING THAT
THEY DESERVE LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND ALSO THE PROVIDERS AND ALSO
THE CONSUMER'S WE'RE GONNA GET
THIS THING THAT WE'VE GOT SIX
I'VE GOT SIX MORE YEARS LEFT
IN IN THE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IF THE PEOPLE KEEP ELECTING
ME EVERY TWO YEARS BUT MY
COMMITMENT IS TO TO YOU THE
NEXT SIX YEARS WE'RE GONNA
DO THIS I'M NOT AFRAID WE DID
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
TOOK ME TWO YEARS FOUR MONTHS
AND SIX DAYS TO GET THAT SIGN
OKAY WE HAVE SIX YEARS IS A
LOT WE CAN DO TOGETHER THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH TONIGHT